good morning everyone
welcome to the
february 28th
session of the science technology and
energy committee
i would like you all to stand with me
and observe a moment of silence
in solidarity with the ukrainian people
please remain standing while
ukrainian-american lex brezhney leads us
in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge
allegiance of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
right
thank you everyone
we're here this morning for an executive
session
we plan to
pass judgment on 10
st e bills today
and
we'll build we'll be doing this again
tomorrow
an instant replay if you will tomorrow
we will exec 10 more bills
and those 20 bills will complete
our work for
today
and for this year actually
good point
representative platt
so that's our agenda for today and
tomorrow we'll start that shortly but
first
i'd like to
welcome some new members to the
committee today we have some substitute
members who are
filling in for members who couldn't be
here today so
i'd like to say hello to representative
laura
telerisky
she's in for ken vincent welcome
representative
and representative linda massimilia is
in for peter samsich
welcome representative
and representative george sykes is in
for
representative mcwilliams so
welcome to our committee the three of
you it's nice to have you here today
i'd like to remind everybody of the
microphone edit etiquette in this
committee
if you wish to
speak
i urge you to turn your microphone on
once you have completed speaking i ask
that you turn your microphone off
pretty simple
before we get started with our executive
sessions i want to address an issue that
some people have expressed some concern
about
on january 7th
and then again on february 17th
the stne committee tabled
several bills that were pending before
the house
now some people have suggested that
we're trying to stifle debate
and i want to
put that suggestion to bed it is not
true we're not trying to stifle debate
as you all well know
st e bills tend to come up late in the
day because of where we
reside in the calendar alphabet
and leadership approached me on both
those days
and requested that i tabled those bills
in order to allow the sessions to end in
a timely fashion
both those
session days
the debates that had been scheduled
would have lasted a minimum of an hour
and we were nearing the end of our
session time
and so the leadership team asked me to
to table those bills which i did
reluctantly i didn't want to i wanted
the debates to happen but
in the interest of time i decided that
was the prudent course of action
so i wanted to clear the air about that
let everybody know that we're not trying
to stifle debate
i see a couple of members would like to
respond representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman so
i understand that and it makes perfect
sense and i'm just wondering if
now that we're going to be in
legislative hall if that is
less likely to happen
i could not predict what what will
happen once we get back into reps hall
but the hope is
that our session life will return more
to normal going forward and so that
being the case we would hope we wouldn't
have to do that too often going forward
representative mann
yes maybe i don't understand but
given that it takes a
substantial vote to take those two bills
off the table
are we going to get cooperation from the
republican party in taking these off the
table
once again i can't predict what will
happen in the future
i will say that if there is time to take
bills off the table so that they can be
debated that could happen but i can't
predict it one way or the other
ah thank you for your question though
did you have a follow-up yes follow-up
um i was asking if um
if the situation ever comes up
where it's possible
to have some time to take those two
bills off the table would we
be um would it be possible to be for the
republican
delegation to uh
assert that they will in fact support
taking it off the table since it was
only done for a
reason unrelated to the
bill itself
the bills we can discuss excuse me
we can discuss that with our caucus i
can't predict what the outcome will be
of that discussion
um
somebody else had a question
oh representative notter
thank you i just made an obvious
observation i've never seen your face
and i didn't know who you were
representative
pimentel
representative partial had a comment yes
asking uh uh
sheriff
asking to address your institutional
memory are these bills ever taken out of
their alphabetical order
or are we always going to be victims of
our committee starting with the letter s
no
it has happened in the past that
when the calendar was so full of bills
that they split it into two
two separate calendars
sometimes they reverse the order in one
or the other of those two calendars so
it is possible that we might hear our
bills earlier in the day at some point
in the future but
it's up to the leadership team and the
clerk to make that schedule
without follow-up yes uh if i may
without our advocacy is there any way
you could advocate for uh reordering or
no i would be happy to do it for you
being supportive
that that typically doesn't happen okay
thank you okay
representative callie pitts
um
one if there's something that's a
particular interest
we can always request a special order
yes that is correct that is correct
all right i just wanted to clear the air
on that subject i appreciate all your
comments and uh
now i look forward to conducting the
business of the day
so
with that i'd like to open an exec
session on house bill
1012 relative to notice for the cutting
of trees by utilities
and i recognize
representative jose cambrils
thank you mr chairman uh i would like to
make a motion to itl house bill 1012.
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge
house bill 1012 to be itl is there any
discussion i'll start the discussion by
informing the committee of a phone call
that i had with vice president michael
lacata of new hampshire
electric co-op
about two days after the public hearing
on this bill
mr licotta went back to his management
team at the co-op and asked them to
investigate the specific charges that
were leveled against the co-op during
that public hearing
he did so and they discovered that they
had a very well documented paper trail
about every
aspect of the
issues that the
public hearing supposedly revealed about
their handling of the tree cutting
situation in wolfeboro
and according to mr lakota the the paper
trail showed
that most of what we heard in testimony
was not true
for example
someone testified that he had called
police
during the tree cutting operation
when the record revealed that the police
were called two days later
he also said he
spoke to the tree cutting crew the day
that the tree cutting happened
when in fact he wasn't even in town
until two days later that's why he
called the police two days later
and there were other examples of
errors in the record with regard to this
gentleman's testimony
given that reality and given the reality
that
passing legislation based on a single
incident is never a good idea i will be
voting to support the itl motion is
there further discussion representative
mcgee yes thank you mr chairman i'd just
like to mention that i also spoke with
mr lakota and i was a co-sponsor on the
bill with dr marsh who this was his
constituent
and
another point that came out after
the fact is that the bill was written in
order to change the requirements around
notice if trees are going to be removed
and
when when mike licotta went back and
looked in the records of the new
hampshire
electric co-op
proper notice had been given so within
the statute that we currently have the
rules were all followed
so there's no need for the bill
representative callie pitts
don't forget to use your microphone
please
mr licotte has been busy and i also
spoke to him and and i will bring up the
same thing that i brought up
uh
at the hearing is that we have discussed
this and fully to taking care of this
matter of tree cutting in the past
so that when we do legislation we really
have to try to do some research about
what
already exists
and what kind of agreements already
exist between
i know that each one of us wants to
serve our constituents as best as we can
but it's not always with a hammer
further discussion on
house bill
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
on the motion of itl for hb 1012
representative thomas
yes
representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative plett votes
yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes uh is
representative lewicki present
okay
let's see
representatives uh representative
massimilla
yes can i pronounce that correctly yes
uh representative callie pitts
represent okay representative mann
yes why do we have
i have you crossed out for some reason
representative oxen hold on
you are definitely here
okay and that's because i was changing
the role for the other substitutes and
somehow you get crossed out by mistake
representative oxenoum
okay
representative tallersky
yes
representative mcgee
representative sykes
yes representative creation
yes representative pimentel yes
a representative partial yes
representative votes
yes
ah come on
that makes it 21 0 0. there's one absent
consent
21 0
1 yeah
okay by a vote of 21 to nothing
the itl motion of 8 on hb 1012 is
adopted without objection we'll put this
on the consent calendar
i see no objection
so we'll close the executive session on
house bill 1012.
i will now open the executive session on
house bill
1116 relative to renewable energy
customer generator accounts
and credits
and i will recognize representative
notter thank you mr chairman i move itl
i move to second
representatives notter and harrington
have moved and seconded the motion to
itl house bill
1116 is there any discussion
representative oxenom
could we hear a rationale for the itl
motion
representative nader did you want to
okay
i will say that um
there was a there were two major
problems with this bill one is an
expansion of net metering
that probably should be studied before
it's implemented and the second problem
is
a more delicate one i would say
and that is
the sponsor of the bill
had a family farm that would directly
benefit from the bill which seemed to be
a
pretty significant conflict of interest
so i don't think it's worthwhile to go
forward with such a bill in that uh
given those circumstances any further
discussion yeah yeah
representative
callie pitts
um
i'd i'd like to comment on what the uh
speaker just said
there's no conflict of interest unless
you declare a conflict of interest and
you can declare it i don't believe this
was a conflict of interest this was
basically a bill and i don't know if the
people who are here are up to snuff on
it to combine accounts if you had more
than one account
and that would entail
some some uh
computer changes some
and some i believe some expense on the
part of the utilities to combine those
that's what the basic premise of the
bill was
so i
i don't believe there was any
malice because representative oxen
resident creation
representative wall senator
senator waters i don't believe
that there was an absolute conflict and
i would leave that out of it i i just
think that the combining of these
accounts
might in the future be a very good idea
if you have more than one account why
not put them together
but at this point i don't think we have
enough information on how it would be
done
thank you representative uh mcgee
thank you mr chairman yeah i just wanted
to sort of reiterate that
on the first point of expanding that
metering this wouldn't actually expand
anything it just says if you have
multiple accounts and you have a credit
on one you can apply it to the other and
that's kind of a way of balancing
the um expenses that you have
uh i i think that
representative mick williams
understanding the situation came from
the fact that she's one of those
customers but there are other people
besides her that she was thinking of
when she was trying to figure out a way
to
accommodate that particular situation
which i think makes perfect sense
on the notes that i have here the only
um question that i had was the
effectiveness dates 60 days after might
not be
possible for the implementation as we
discussed there might be system updates
that would be required to allow the
billing to do what she's asking it to do
um but
uh
you know that would be more of an
amendment than a than an itl so
representative plett has a comment yes i
think i'm the only
committee member who actually worked for
utility
psnh
what she's asking is a building
nightmare
it would involve a huge amount of uh
cost
to to implement it's just and that's the
what i walked away with when we heard
the bill to me this is an itl because
it's so complex
any further discussion representative
cam girls
oh sorry representative harrington
not to correct fred all the time but i
also worked for utility fred
anyways that's one of the reasons this
be creates a problem is it's not limited
to a single utility if you could have a
customer would have multiple accounts
one with unitil and one with
eversource and i don't know how this
would work it doesn't address that and
there is going to be cost associated
with it that the utility would simply
pass on to ratepayers if we wanted to
look at something like this in the
future any cost associated with
implementing this should be paid by the
people getting the advantage of it and
not just put it into general rates
that's why i support the
ito thank you representative
on the issue of conflict of interest
you turned your mic off
now it's on now
so red red is on and green is off right
great
on the issue of conflict of interest
i've spoken with the legal counsel
formerly of the puc now of the
department of energy
and people who have renewable energy are
not conflicted out from
discussing issues related to the fact
that they are renewable energy owners
this notion that there's an unfair
advantage is one that i had hoped to by
this time we would have dispelled people
who have invested in renewable energy
have sacrificed in order to do so they
have been incentivized by the state to
do so because the state finds it in the
interests of the state that there be
more distributed energy resources and
that we be less reliant on fossil fuels
therefore measures have been instituted
to incentivize people to spend their own
money and invest in an investment that
does not return at all
in commence commensurate with a market
investment that you could have made at
the same time there's a substantial
opportunity cost for having made this
secondly in terms of the particular
representative she has filed conflict of
interest uh the ethics form excuse me
the disclosure to say that she is a
renewable energy user so that is on
record
and uh the final point was about the
cost of implementation we've been told
again and again by the utilities
that they do this by hand they they have
not
automated how they manage these accounts
so the the notion that there has to be
this enormous billing change
it's all done by hand already
i appreciate representative harrington's
comment about multiple utilities i think
that's a very rare instance but it's
certainly one in which if were we to
send this bill to the senate it could be
considered and and added in it has as it
has been in the group host net metering
that you must be in the same utility or
it doesn't apply
thank you
thank you representative ox and i'm any
further discussion representative
pementel
thank you mr chairman
if we do manage to not itl this
there is an amendment
that has been submitted
uh
0.737
which addresses the issue of uh
that it have they have to be
in the same utility and it also
addresses the mechanism to um
to recover costs for the utilities for
any kind of upgrades
the other thing i want to mention is
that there are
people now
residents who have
two meters
because they have
every source
allows people to put in a second meter
for their
heating
which get a different rate
if that person
puts on put solar panels on
they're not going to be able to
uh
include both of those metered
uh costs just one of them
so this bill would solve that problem
okay thank you any uh additional
comments
representative callie pitts this this
committee has never
well i won't say never
but has a reputation for not walking
away from complicated or
complex issues that's what we're about
that's what we're supposed to be about
my problem with this bill if there is a
pending amendment i can't vote on
something i don't see
and my problem
is very simple
something my mother used to say to me
all the time the devils and the details
and we don't have the details so i think
this is a worthy subject
it needs more work there's a way you we
can put it off
and put it into interim study
but i have a feeling that interim study
we have one bill in there already and i
don't think two will happen we are a
committee that's supposed to be handling
complexities
thank you
further discussion
seeing none i would like to ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
itl for house bill 1116.
representative
representative thomas
as a t.h.o
yes
thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative plett says yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
mocking representative lewis
not president representative massa
miller
no
representative kelly pitts
yes
represent a man
yes yes
yes represent oxygen
no representative tallersky no
representative mcgee no representative
sykes
no representative creature no
representative pimentel no
rep uh representative partial
yes
one
two three four five six seven
i have 13 8 and 1.
right okay by a vote of 13 to 8
the motion to itl house bill 1116
carries so i will call the executive
session for 11 16. it is not 13 to 8.
okay sorry
it's hard to read this thing one two
three four all right hang on let's get
the correct vote count eleven through
white
twelve thirteen
thirteen eight
the wiki is not present and i ha that's
it thirteen eight one
there's twenty-two
my apology
all right so the
the count of 13 to eight is correct and
the motion to itl house bill 1116 passes
and so we will close the public hearing
on house bill 11 16.
i will now open a public hearing on
house bill 1328
exact session i'm sorry
public hearings and exec sessions
so we're going to open an exec session
on house bill 1328
fm
the both bills representative mcgee
will there be a minority report for
house bill 1116.
mcwilliams
doug
i'm gonna make a motion here before we
get going so
uh please inform representative williams
that we need that by the close of
business today if possible
representative harrington is recognized
i'd like to make a motion on uh hb 1328
ought to pass
representative
harrington moves ought to pass on house
bill
1328 representative mr champion is
recognized mr chairman i'd like to uh
second the motion
okay the motion is seconded by
representative murder
so we have moved and seconded the motion
to
of ought to pass on house bill
1328 is there any discussion
representative harrington
yeah this is just an another step in our
deregulation of telephones uh that's
been going on for quite some time uh
maine and vermont have had similar laws
for over six years without any problems
uh there is some form of this law in 38
other states and it's just no reason to
hold on to the old uh you know a t and t
marbell regulations that are no longer
necessary
thirteen twenty thirteen twenty quarter
house bill
1328 is what we're working on
what exactly representative oxen are you
passing out
thank you mr chair i'm passing out an
information sheet that speaks to
questions that were raised and not
answered at the public hearing on 13 28.
it's being passed around
i'm sorry
okay thank you in fact i need one myself
i seem to pass them all out
do you want to be recognized to speak to
this uh
sheet that you passed out
i i would thank you very much if i could
just wait one moment while i get handed
a copy here i'll give you that copy
i'm sorry we've always
done this in numerical order and
calling it
it caught me unawares
the handout
seeks to answer several questions that
were raised at the public hearing to
which we did not have an answer
um i
downloaded this from
the
nri which is a research institute
attached to the national public
utilities commission organization
whose initials i no longer remember
the beginning
colr is the abbreviation for carrier of
last resort
and the question was raised during the
hearing
why we would be discussing this at this
point in time
so many states have begun to re-examine
their carrier of last resort
obligation
um if you turn to the second page which
is the conclusions and recommendations
of this um lengthy and uh detailed study
that was produced in 2016
you'll find
that um
i think it's it's actually going to be
quicker if i just read you a couple of
key sentences kohler policies have been
a critical part of ensuring universal
access to telecommunications services
competition
and the transition to broadband have
reduced but not eliminated the need to
designate a carrier that will be
available to provide service in areas
where competition has not taken root
the kohler would continue to be
designated by the state commission but
need not be the islet or provide service
using any specific technology then
skipping down to the next paragraph
kohler policies provide a backstop for
areas where competitive carriers may
choose to withdraw service and those
areas where carriers may fail or may
abandon service altogether in these
areas the designation of a carrier of
last resort remains important rather
than anachronistic
kohler duties remain a key means of
ensuring the universal availability of
both voice and broadband services
the modifications to these requirements
described in this paper
particularly expanding it to broadband
include limitations on kohler service
where competition provides customers
with options and the acceptance of
alternate technologies which will help
ensure the requirement remains viable
so
in their conclusion states considering
legislation to change or abandon kohler
requirements should consider the
following questions in developing their
recommendations on this subject
how should color requirements be defined
should they be broadened to include
broadband should callers be required to
offer basic service and if so what are
the minimum requirements is competition
in areas with limitations on service
sufficient to ensure that at least one
carrier capable of offering service to
all
will remain
how should that level of competition be
reviewed how should competition be
measured must a competitive provider be
available to all customers in an area
before the existing caller is allowed to
exit
what process should the state use to
ensure that competition continues to
provide affordable service and that it
is available to all
the point here is that we have a series
of questions which were raised in the uh
in the public hearing
and the
um it's clear nationwide that this is an
issue that is under consideration and i
feel that this this bill is premature
in seeking to cut off
access to this lifeline of
communications and i propose that
we vote down the itl or i'm sorry is
this not to pass
yes yes
i propose that we vote down the ought to
pass and instead send this to interim
service the the questions which are
registered here in the recommendations
of this study demonstrate that we need
to look at this take it very seriously
this can be in fact a matter of life and
death to our constituents
and we should be protective of their
interests thank you
thank you representative oxenom for
bringing this study to our attention
representative plett has a comment yes
i'd respond i
disagree with my esteemed colleague
because in the bill itself it says that
the
uh the the only way the department of
energy can approve a petition
uh to uh
be relieved of carrier of last resort is
that the
uh at least one wire line facilities
based voice network service provider
other than incumbent offers service to
at least 95 percent of the households in
the municipality and one or more mobile
telecommunications service provider
office on the aggregate mobile
telecommunications service release 97
of the households in the municipality
and i think even if abandoned carry a
last resort they still have to keep
9-1-1 service active
further discussion representative
cretian
the point that i wanted to to highlight
in this um is i guess related to
representative plet's last point that
this will require um some effort by the
department of energy to actually analyze
these things um i noticed in the fiscal
note that this will require likely the
employment of some consultants ranging
between fifty thousand and a hundred
thousand dollars um i'm not convinced
that this is an urgent enough issue for
the state to to kill um to pay to kill i
guess um that's my only comment
further discussion representative callie
pitts
all through these last few weeks and
hearings i've been very concerned with
9-1-1 and what we used to call
left-in-dial tone
and
that is not mandatory at this point and
i was surprised to hear that
i do believe that this bill should go
forward i believe it should because
you can't just fold up shop and leave
it's not like a business
yet you can just
leave
so i i don't think it's going to leave
anyone in a lurch
but i do
and want to correct that point about
9-1-1 because i asked that question
during the hearing
and they said no they do not have to
leave that in
thank you
i will point out that during the course
of the public hearing on this bill we
heard that
relieving the incumbent utilities
of this obligation will reduce costs
which is important to all of us
and it will also
remove a public utilities commission
assessment which is no longer needed
because the public utilities commission
does not regulate
these services so those are two good
reasons why we should we should pass
this bill
is there any further discussion
representative thomas thank you mr chair
in addition to what has been said i also
believe this bill should be passed
not only because of on its merits but it
gives this
our folks on the other side of the wall
a chance to have further discussion into
this bill
to i'm sure they will come up with some
tweaks along the way to make it an
actually even better bill so it's
another reason for passing this bill i
believe our friends on the other side
will be discussing this at length to
come up with
some some agreement
further discussion
representative oxenom
thank you mr chair
just to
respond to representative plett's uh
informed comment about the text of the
bill
95 percent and 97
is not 100
and as i represent an area which has
substantial areas of
non-coverage by alternatives i'm very
concerned about moving forward uh with
with an issue once again
it's all about saving pennies on the
dollar and not being protective of the
interests of the people that we came
here to represent
i'm not asking that we
foreclose this bill i'm asking that we
send it to interim study so that the the
really profound issues that are raised
here can be considered in greater depth
than a 10-minute discussion uh by this
committee
representative harrington is recognized
yeah i hear this i'm going to make a
statement that i would if you would ask
me six months ago or a few years ago i
would have said no way
on saturday i opened up my mailbox and
what was in there it was a card from a
company that is going to excuse me be
expanding uh
fiber broadband into strafford the town
that i live in which is a very rural
community it's about 50 square miles
about 4 000 people
and i would never thought the day would
come when competition would be a present
in my choice of broadband
but now it is or it's going to be
shortly i think that's the way we're
heading uh between satellites and fiber
and traditional uh cable and telephone
service uh people aren't running away
you're gonna have more options not less
in the future
thank you further discussion
representative pementel is recognized
thank you mr chairman uh
i agree with uh
the representative that
that is the way we are moving
but we're not there yet
95 percent is not a hundred percent
um
if we remove
uh
kohler from one carrier we're not giving
it to another so in fact anyone in that
area no longer
has or will have
a
carrier of last resort
thank you representative
further discussion representative callie
bits
it is my belief and i would like uh
representative harrington who was a
public utilities commissioner
to please correct me if i'm wrong but
they can't do that they can't just
abandon and leave customers without
service
because when they go for the petition
to do that there has to be
somebody else who's going to take it
over now is it going to be at the same
price no
i don't know maybe less maybe more
but they can't just abandon and leave
people
in the lurch with no service
i i believe that's correct can can
anybody correct me
representative harrington
i i don't know the technicalities of
that uh that thing i know a lot of
requirements have been removed from the
telephone companies over the years from
back when they were very heavily
regulated but as to that particular one
um you know maybe there's someone that
represents the utilities or one of the
companies that could answer the question
but i don't know the answer
representative
oxenam thank you very much mr chair for
taking my question i think this is
exactly the reason why we need interim
study this is a vital point on which we
have differing uh
memories of what was said or not said at
the the issue came up at the public
hearing but it was not resolved i was
not able to resolve it in the research
that i did outside of the committee and
i am left with the impression that in
fact yes that's exactly what will happen
there will be no coverage if this bill
passes in its current state
representative
[Music]
mcgee
thank you mr chairman um just to follow
on that last point my question was
if if
if the carriers are still required to
provide service or there needs to be an
alternative service then why are we
removing
carrier of last resort coverage in the
first place who who does it benefit and
who does it
uh no longer benefit because it seems
like that it seems like we're picking
sides on either side of that argument
saying this is fine that is fine but to
representative oxenum's point we don't
have the answers and so i think it's
it's not responsible of us to move
forward with something where we're
really not
we don't have certitude uh either way
thank you representative callie pitts
when i first spoke i asked for some
correction and some help or maybe some
clarification
there is a representative from
the industry here
and i wonder if they could clarify that
one point because that seems to be the
sticking point for a lot of people that
we're going to leave
people in a lurch and we won't do that
it's not permitted
and
to my knowledge the way i think of it so
i would ask your indulgence would you
allow miss rosenberger to clarify that
position
i would allow it if ms rosenberger is so
inclined
if you would please come up and sit at
the table and turn on the microphone
thank you and then turn it off
teresa rosenberger bernstein sure i
represent the new hampshire telephone
association which are all the landline
telephone companies all the original
mobile companies
which is consolidated tds granite state
bretton woods
dunbarton and it used to be dixville
and to your point
when the balsams is and i think i
explained this during the hearing when
the balsams was running dixville
telephone had a lot of customers and
after the balsams closed at one point
dixville telephone had five customers
it's extraordinarily expensive to
maintain a
operation for five customers
dixie telephone asked to be relieved of
their
obligation to serve
that area it took us
at least four years and it may have
taken longer than that we had to and i
represented dixville telephone and my
law firm represented them in the whole
process we had to get puc approval we
had to get fcc approval but more
importantly
before we could do that step at all we
had to run all sorts of tests and assure
that every single customer that we had
had service and they could get service
from someone else whether it be
wireless whether it be cable etc so and
then on top of that and i'm sorry kate
bailey isn't still a commissioner
because
we had quite a conversation about it
because we had to not only make sure
that
they had
alternative service and they had more
than one choice but we had to also
assure that they wanted to take the
service and there was one gentleman who
i will not name his name who
really didn't like one of the other
carriers and and said nope not approving
because i don't like that carrier so
anyway eventually he
he found a carrier he liked but we could
not give up a service in that territory
or we could not be approved to give it
up without puc and fcc approval and it
was very costly it took quite quite a
while
thank you i would like to or thank you i
would like to restrict this line of
questioning to that one question
uh so thank you ms rosenberger i
appreciate that
representative oxendum do
thank you very much wait a minute for
taking my question but no i just want to
i want to say one thing
that applies to all the mob elk all the
monopolistic companies not just
dicksville so if consolidated wanted to
go out of business or granite state or
whoever they'd have to go through the
same process great okay thank you my
question is that was the law
before this change came into being the
question is
this bill will change that
law after passage of this will that
still be that will still be the case
it what what is the where is the
requirement it's in the law and it's in
the federal law and the state law
it's current we're not we're not
changing this is not changing the
deregulation statute that we passed what
2012 maybe
so the current law
if let's just say for example
dunbarton telephone
asked to give up their carry of last
resort because their their service area
was totally covered
fine
they can give up the carry of last
resort if the puc agrees they have 95
and 75.
dunbarton telephone cannot give up being
a telephone company
in their service territory without puc
and fcc approval
this has nothing to do with that law yes
but but you preface your remarks by
saying representative
i didn't give you permission to follow
up could you uh mr chair
ask to be recognized please point of
order please
yes representative thomas yes i'd like
to remind the committee here as much as
they like to to respect the cheers
ruling on issues or or challenge and
call a vote please respect the decorum
thank you
representative oxenam
do you have a final comment on this bill
yes sir thank you very much and uh thank
you representative thomas we all
enjoy the
um
the final remarks were prefaced by the
words under current law this this is the
nub of the issue
will this bill
make things different and i i believe
what we heard prior to that last
edition
was that there are other there are other
laws that provide
for this coverage
to remain universal it so my question is
is that your understanding of the
remarks that we heard because it seemed
to be contradicted in the very last
remarks which were prefaced by the words
under current law
the question is what will this bill do
representative harrington can you
address that question
i don't have an exact copy of the bill
in front of me right here i'll have to
dig one up someone got one
my understanding is if the criteria are
met
then they will um
they will lose they will no longer be
required to be the supplier of last
resort so that that's the 95 97 and
again i bring this up as
it's ongoing has been in maine in
vermont for the last six years 38 states
have similar laws there haven't been
problems there the amount of uh
opportunities uh for different options i
should say for different types of
telephone service and broadband service
are only going up they're not going down
so i just think this is a holdover from
the days of long past that we don't need
anymore
all right representative christian give
you the last word
i guess maybe a question for
representative harrington
it sounds like from what we just heard
that this is
kind of already
addressable that they can already
petition the puc so i guess i don't
understand the need for this change if
it
is already something that they can ask
for
my understanding is they still would
have with the franchise you
franchise comes that carrier of last
resort requirement this would remove
that so we basically be lying on the
market to supply telephones and as i
said earlier there's not been a shortage
of it going down i don't know of any
place that says boy we had much better
telephone coverage much better broadband
coverage must be wireless coverage 20
years ago than we have now every place
you go there's there's more options not
less so i just don't think it's it's a
problem that doesn't exist
okay
i think we've
exhausted discussion on this topic so we
have a motion on the floor to
move that
hb 1328 be judged ought to pass and i'd
ask the clerk to call the roll
thank you mr chair i shall do so
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platt votes
yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambros yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
wiki not present markings so
uh
representative massimilia no
i accidentally put you down as a yes i'm
trying to fix it
ah come on
so fixed uh representative kelly pitts
representative mann
representative oxenom no
representative uh tallerski no
representative mcgee
no representative seis
no representative creation no
representative pimentel no
representative partial
and the chairman yes
12 yes
one absent which means
one two three four five six seven
through preaching
eight
nine nine no
that's
wait a second that can't be right yes
yes
okay by a vote of 12 yes and
nine
with one abstention or one person not
voting
the motion about to pass
is approved
will there be a minority report
yes representative occidental i'm afraid
i cannot do it by the close of business
today i have several blurbs for for
other bills that and i i don't
that's
all right would you like to assign it to
someone else i would i would like to
have a little more time is there a
reason why they need to be in today
yes they have to be to the clerk by noon
on wednesday we're trying to get this in
for the march 10th session yes
no that's too late because i have to
approve all the reports before they are
submitted to the clerk so
we have to get them submitted to our
leadership before they go to you and and
who depending on how long we're here
today i i think it's unreasonable we're
going to be meeting march i believe it's
march 17th and 18th with the possibility
of the 31st
okay i'll give you until uh
the end of day tomorrow how's that thank
you very much i
greatly appreciate that however if i
don't have your report in time it will
not be submitted to the clerk thank you
very much sir
all right so let's close the executive
session
on house bill
and uh
we'll move on now to open
an executive session on house bill 1148
relative to prohibiting government
entities subordinate to the state
from restricting the types of fuel
sources that may be used for energy
and the chair recognizes representative
plett yes thank you mr chair i move out
to pass on house bill 1148
representative blaget is recognized
yes thank you chair i'd like to second
the motion ought to pass around 11 48.
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge house bill 1148
should be ought to pass is there any
discussion representative platt yes this
is an extension of what something was
done last year for heating systems this
is
extending beyond heating systems to fuel
sources for
generation or conversion
and a town is or municipality is still
able to go to a site evaluation
committee and either support or oppose
and but they are not
this would
this would take away the
power to
change zoning just to defeat a project
uh projects have to follow zoning but
the town municipality can't throw throw
in a monkey wrench by changing zoning or
doing any other
action other than protests at the site
evaluation committee
and it is not directed at any one
generation source or conversion about
everything that proposed is opposed
okay further discussion on this bill
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um you know my impressions when i looked
at this bill initially are that this
will
affect local control yes
uh it will also it could potentially
interfere with
town planning that has already been
undertaken
for
locations that are trying to get
themselves to 100 renewable for their
municipal buildings and there are
several examples of those types of towns
that have those types of plans
and so
i think
it's
it's really reaching into local control
to solve a problem that isn't there and
the decisions that folks are making
locally
are not inhibiting
the growth of any particular type of
fuel and so
i i would question the need for us to
impose more limits on the local control
for how people plan their own energy
futures
further discussion
here
representative mann
i just wanted to
point out that the city of keene for
example sits in kind of a hollow
and on with people burning wood um
it gets pretty nasty
and i think the
city of cane should have the right to
restrict
fuel sources for heating
simply on that basis for public health
and so that's an example of public
health in general and
i think local situations should be uh
considered
okay thank you representative platt i
remind
representative mann that this is
directed towards energy generation or
conversion
uh what he was his example he used was
heating and that was made illegal last
year
okay representative callie pitts has a
question i'd just like to remind the
committee that
it was said that the uh
they could be an appeal will appeals go
both ways
the generator can appeal as well as the
town so we you know
i think we shouldn't make a law to
prohibit that
and i think we need to leave it the way
it is there are a lot of
plants that are closing and
things that may be coming in and if we
hold planning boards or
boards of adjustment or zoning boards
as
the virgin mary we're wrong they change
zoning all the time but i think that
energy needs to be a consideration and
the type of energy
what your neighbors are breathing
is extremely important not only to the
health of the town
to the health of the individuals
thank you representative callie pitts
i'd remind the members of the committee
that
new hampshire is not a home rule state
and local municipalities local
governments can only do
what the state gives them permission to
do and that's where this bill would fall
into that category this the state would
be
saying no to permission to
uh prohibiting any kind of fuel use
representative sykes had a comment
actually i have a question not a comment
mr chair
um
do i understand correctly that part two
of this bill
which in in lines 14 15 and and 16 would
make zoning changes that a community had
made in prior years
void now if it concerns municipal energy
questions
i'll let representative plett answer
that question that is correct
wow okay further discussion
representative oxenom
thank you very much for taking the
question mr chair i'm very concerned
that part two is
retroactively changing
laws that had been passed
by
our towns and our
unincorporated places
that that we have
had many towns i believe the numbers in
excess of 20 who have
designated that they want to move to 100
renewable energy by a date certain
they've undertaken
investment programs they've undertaken
bonding
on the basis of the fact that this was
within their purview i think for the
state to step in at this point and make
this kind of a unilateral
declaration would be harmful to our
local businesses
harmful to
our efforts to move in a different
direction with fuel sources
and that it would it would take us
backwards and probably bring the uh
i won't go into probably i i think it's
a very bad idea and i'll be voting
against it
okay further discussion on this bill
representative partial
yes thank you chair
in 2017 there was a
lawsuit between liberty utilities
and the city of concord
um concerning some of the areas that
this uh
bill would address and while the court
ultimately found in favor of the
municipality for what
uh
decisions they could make
an understanding also we are not a uh
home rule
either see this as opening up as uh
potentially opening up another reopening
that lawsuit
and uh for the sake of efficiency i just
think that we should be cautious around
these things
which is why i
while i'm not actually opposed to the
bill itself
i can't
support an otp on it
okay
any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion of ought to pass
on house bill
what's the number of this 11 48 thank
you
thank you mr chair
representative thomas
yes
representative harrington yes
representative otter yes representative
mirner yes representative plett votes
yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent of
cambrils yes represent yes
representative white yes uh
representative not present
representative massa miller no
representative callie pitts
represent a man
no that was a no i got it
i'm just
marking
representative oxenoum no
present first before i record her no i i
went through and copied and pasted all
the roll calls so i have to fix them all
okay
so no i got to know rep telersky no
represent mcgee no represent no
represent creature
represent pimentel
representative partial
and the chairman
yes
eleven nine one
ten one
okay by a vote of 11 to 10 the ought to
pass motion on house bill
1148 is adopted will there be a minority
report and if so by whom yes i'll it'll
be me it'll be who me
representative mcgee okay
please have that by close of business
tomorrow if not sooner
thank you
we have neglected up to this point to be
reading the blue sheets
uh this is not a public hearing
oh that's right this is not a public
hearing okay
that's the reason we haven't been doing
goodness gracious it's great to have a
good reason to do something
i'm getting requests for a bio break
but what i would like to do instead is
have a lunch break
and uh
since it is now
110 1105 i guess we're pretty close to
it
i think we're going to do a lunch break
now so
or at least after we do one other piece
of business
and that other piece of business is not
directly related to a
public an executive session i'm not sure
i closed the executive session on 11 48
so i'll do that now so that is
officially closed and there is one other
piece of business i would like to
conduct
before we
break for our
our lunch break and that is
representative oxenam requested a work
session on house bill 1645
which is scheduled for
executive session tomorrow
so what i would like to do is i would
like to get a sense of the committee
about whether or not we want to hold a
work session on house bill 1645 if we do
then we'll schedule that
for maybe
one or two o'clock tomorrow afternoon
and then have the exact exact session
immediately following
we have to post any work sessions 24
hours before they
happen
so if we're going to do this we need to
post it outside the door here
sooner rather than later later
so
i think what i would like to do is have
a short discussion about whether or not
we want to have this work session
and then i'd like to take a vote of the
committee to find out if we're going to
do so
so
is there any discussion on this
subject representative oxenam since it's
your request i'll let you have the first
word thank you very much mr chair yes uh
it's a complex bill i have a
handout which unlike the one i just gave
you on a different bill was back to
front on one page this is back to front
on about 15 pages and i i really think
we could we could get through it in 10
minutes but i think it takes it takes a
little bit of more time than we've been
giving in our executive sessions and i i
would ask you to please allow us the
opportunity to present the bill so that
it is fully understood at the time that
we
moved to a vote thank you
okay further discussion representative
plett i find this request very untimely
we're in exact session today and
tomorrow with 10 bills each we just
haven't got the time there's plenty of
time to ask for this earlier
representative
platt thank you any further discussion
representative callie pitts
i think any one of us in here could at
any time
make a request of the chair
and out of deference
and out of respect for my fellow
representative
if there's new information to be heard
or different information to be heard
i would vote in favor of that
we
i understand time constraints
but i don't think we're that constrained
and i i really do think that in re out
of respect
i i would approve that i'm never
hesitant to listen
uh further comments on this question
about whether we should have a work
session tomorrow on house bill
uh 1645 representative partial
yes could you repeat again how long do
you think this work session would
take
an estimate representative oxenam
thank you mr chair um i'm i'm saying
that i believe i could present this
information in about 10
minutes
but
how long the work session where people
might raise questions about it i think
that i i don't believe it would be more
than a half an hour at a maximum but
that's i guess
okay thank you
further discussion on the question of
whether we should have a work session on
hb 1645 representative pimentel
personally if anyone here made a request
for a work session i would be in favor
of it
i think that
in deference to my colleague i think
that it is important that
we have we definitely have the time
um
this is not gonna
if that makes us stay here a half an
hour longer
um
but we've uh done our due diligence
let's get it done
okay any further comment
the reason i've asked for a vote is
because
this is a democratic body so i thought
the
the organization the group should make
the decision about whether to do this or
not representative oxendine do you have
another comment i just wanted to
apologize to the chair for speaking out
of turn um when i said that i had made
the request
a week ago
but i
and i wanted to apologize to
representative thomas who
had earlier admonished me for
doing so thank you
thank you for your apology no
no problem any further discussion
seeing none i'd like to ask the clerk to
call
all right we can do this by a show of
hands all those in favor of having a
work session on hb 1645 please raise
your hand
11.
all those who are opposed please raise
your hands
okay it looks like we will have a work
session tomorrow on hb
1645.
so i will go
to uh carry morris and we will schedule
that
and
we'll kick that off sometime in the
afternoon on tomorrow and then we'll
immediately follow that work session
with a executive session on hb 1645. so
with that i'm going to call a lunch
break
and uh
let's have everybody be back here at 12
30 to resume the executive sessions we
have
uh let's see one two three four five six
more bills to go so we should be able to
get our work done fairly promptly after
in the early afternoon so thank you
we'll see you at 12 30.
okay
everyone welcome back from lunch i hope
you had a uh
an excellent
refreshment
and now let's get back to work we've got
six bills we need to dispose of here
this afternoon so
welcome everyone watching
on the live stream this is the science
technology and energy committee and we
are having executive sessions today
i was just informed that the
work session the full committee work
session for tomorrow at two o'clock will
be posted within the next half hour so
we two o'clock so that we will be legal
for tomorrow
all right
with that let's now get back to work
and i will open an executive session on
house bill
and
i will recognize representative white
for a most motion
thank you mr chairman i'd like to move
that we uh refer this to interim study
representative bernardi i second that
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we recommend house bill 1248 relative to
replacement power for net metering
customer generators to interim study
is there discussion
representative white did you want to say
anything about your motion yes thank you
um
so as as i testified when i introduced
this bill
uh there are currently issues with it uh
the main issue being that it regulates
an obligation that does not exist
currently
um there were also concerns about how it
might affect or uh disincentivize um
certain types of energy uh insulation
throughout the state there's a number of
complex things with this bill but i do
think there are risk factors as well as
uh we need to look at when that
obligation might be necessary in the
future
so that's why i'd like to refer to
interrupt study
okay further discussion on the motion to
refer this bill to interim study
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
thank you mr chairman
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representative notter
yes representative mirner yes
representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes president of
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
representative lewicki
yes
representative massimilia yes
representative callie pitts
representative mann yes
rep
i have to mark
representative oxenoum is here
representative oxnam yes
well as i said i
copied pace i have to fix each one as i
go through uh
representative tallersky yes
representative mcgee yes representative
sykes yes represent creature yes
uh representative pimentel yes and uh
representative partial yes and the chair
yes
22 to nothing
mr chairman i move we put on consent
and without objection this bill will go
on to consent
the recommendation
to
send hb 1248 to interim study passes 22
to nothing
seeing no objection the bill will go on
consent
and i will close the public hearing on
house bill 1248
of the executive session rather
and i'll open an executive session on
house bill 1250
requiring the public utilities
commission to consider climate change in
making rate setting decisions
and i recognize representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman i move that is
inexpedient to legislate uh 1250.
representative berezini is recognized i
second the motion
it's been moved and seconded that house
bill 1250 be judged to be itl
is there any discussion
representative bernardi
yes
the
public utilities commission is charged
with setting rates that are just and
reasonable or lawful
and
this is for services provided and
observed now these are essentially
financial criteria what's being asked is
is that we judge in environmental
criteria and turn them into some kind of
financial component and uh
and embed them in rates that's just
an almost impossible task particularly
as everyone has different opinion on
what the
issues associated with climate change
are um they're not all bad uh
you know increasing carbon dioxide makes
greater green growth in in the
countryside so
that's a good thing
so
given the fact that it's almost
impossible to turn environmental
criteria into financial criteria
this is inexpedient to legislate
thank you
representative harrington did you have a
comment
i just said i agree with what he said
okay uh representative platt
yes thank you mr chair
the puc doesn't run across climate at
all in its deliberations
uh the closest they come is very
tangential when they approve default
service rates but even then they have no
idea what that where that default
service rate is coming from because it's
it's
it's uh bid by utilities to uh to to get
service
and
and they don't have no idea within that
bid what is actually going to generate
short of that it's all distribution
rates
uh yeah
and and
it's there's just nothing there
okay representative harrington
yeah just a clarification on that i
think by way of example we look at the
storm we faced a couple of weeks ago
um
uh we had a um you know obviously we
lost a lot of wind that was because it
was too windy uh we lost all the solar
because it was snowing out
and on any given day there is no way
that the utility knows where their power
is coming from since they don't generate
their own so on days in january we saw
oil producing over 25 percent of the
electricity in new england
and most other months other than extreme
cold ones you're probably going to see
that number closer to zero but they
don't have any control over it's what's
being put on the grid due to
all sorts of variables with supply and
cost and pipelines and deliverables and
everything else and this would be an
impossible task for the puc to do
because they simply don't know what the
mix of power is because nobody knows
until the actual day when it's generated
thank you additional discussion
representative oxenoum
thank you mr chair
the the actual provision in the rsa
states that
try trying to jump into this sentence in
a way that uh doesn't make me read the
entire paragraph to you but the just and
reasonable was brought up whenever the
commission shall be of the opinion after
a hearing upon its own motion or on
motion of the department of energy or
upon complaint that the rate spares or
charges demanded or collected or
proposed to be demanded or collected by
any public utility for service rendered
or to be rendered or unjust or
unreasonable
or that the regulations or practices of
such public utility affecting such rates
are unjust or unreasonable
or
is a violation of any provision of law
or the maximum rate spheres or charges
is chargeable or insufficient
the commission shall determine the just
and reasonable or lawful rates fares and
charges to be thereafter observed and
enforced as the maximum to be charged
for the service to be performed
and i think that covers
that point
okay so
the issue here um i'm not the sponsor
i'm the co-sponsor and so i'm speaking
for representative gallagher so you'll
permit me to to
suggest what was in his mind when he
spoke to ols
in fact i think ols made an error in
putting this provision into this
particular section of 378. i think that
378 37 and 38 would have made more sense
and i've handed out to everyone
an information sheet that shows
where the
rate setting can actually be affected so
the main point here
is that the pucs decisions can be
legally challenged as arbitrary and
capricious if they are not based on
guidance from this policy-making body so
mr representative gallagher's effort
here is to place climate change which is
one of the most significant issues of
our time
in the rsa so that it is a matter which
must be
or can be and and
someone else can help you on that i
believe i i believe it's a um
a may and not a shell it's because it's
ore or or or
that climate change may be taken into
account in rate setting this is an
effort one to protect public health
two to protect public safety and three
to be proper stewards of ratepayer funds
if the puc is not allowed to take into
account
the fact that a substation may be cited
in such a place it's going to be flooded
and be rendered unusable that's a waste
of the ratepayers money and that money
is recovered in default service charges
similarly if the puc is unable to take
into account the fact that expanding
fossil fuel production may lead to an
increase in our storm damage in our
flooding in our sea levels
then it's not going to be able to
properly plan
how to
proceed with um our energy policy so
that i think that's the explanation for
the purpose of this bill
and i've i've provided an information
sheet that shows
where it might perhaps be uh more
effectively placed thank you
representative harrington is recognized
thank you mr chairman i want to
reiterate this is not a policy issue
where we can just say we're going to do
it or not going to do it this is not
possible to do you don't know who's
going to be generating what day for
example if there was a utility put out a
contract with a supplier and like say
next era and they um were buying power
from seabrook that may get a lot of
their power some days but then cbr could
trip offline and they'd get zero power
from there so the supplier would have to
go get it someplace else maybe that
someplace else is an oil plant maybe
it's a gas plant uh whatever they have
to get it that's part of the deal they
don't sign up with a supplier saying
we'll have so many megawatt hours of gas
and so many megawatt hours of oil and so
many megawatt hours of this they sign up
for megawatt hours period and the
supplier has to develop to deliver that
and that's why we have the system set up
with renewable portfolio standard
there's no requirement that a utility
buy renewable power they just have to
buy the wrecks or make alternative
compliance payments so no one can
control from day to day what percentage
of power is coming from what source it's
just impossible to do the only way you
could do that i guess if you went back
to the way we used to have things years
and years ago have the utilities buy all
their own build all their own power
plants and then you could say we're only
going to allow them to build this type
of plant and that's the only type of
power we would get but short of that
this is simply impossible to implement
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um
i think going back to the initial
discussion that was started by
representative bernardi on the economics
um
i
did not speak with representative
gallagher who was a prime sponsor of the
bill about his
intention for this bill
but i do know that when i attended the
10-year strategy meeting for the iso new
england that the question that i asked
them is if iso is reliability
and and uh kneepole is rates if everyone
is siloed
and no one is taking into account
the cost to our economy
of bringing on more fossil fuel based
um
facilities that end up costing everybody
more
i believe 800 billion was the last
estimate that we heard for climate
related
you know expenses to the united states
it is not nothing
it is an economic issue
and so
uh the discussions around well there's
no way to get a handle on it i believe
that all we were trying to do was say
some agency
in our government
does need to be taking this into
consideration
in terms of how we move forward with the
projects that we approve because
ultimately the cost of those projects
will be increased if the cost of carbon
ends up being you know placed on that
particular type of fuel
and we hear all the time that that's
coming and that 46 other countries are
already adopting carbon pricing so if we
do nothing and we look
uh we look just as as far as our nose
and don't look any further down the road
then i think we're doing a disservice to
the rate payers because these costs are
real
and we can't avoid them by just saying
we don't believe them
so i guess that
i think that the intent of the bill was
to say that the public utilities
commission who reviews facility projects
that come through and what the utilities
are doing in terms of how they're
securing
you know
fuel for our system
that that's the appropriate place to
have the review done
and i don't know who else would be able
to do the review other than them so i
i see it as a very reasonable request
yes people would probably have to change
the way they look at the stuff that
comes across their desk but it's not
it's not asking them to
adjust rate setting on the fly for the
types of
purchases that are happening on a
day-to-day market i don't think that's
the intent of the bill
so that's that's like a red herring
taking us in another direction it's just
saying when you're looking at these
facility projects that are coming across
your desk you have to take it into
account because there's a cost
associated with it and there's a cost
associated with it if we don't look at
that
thank you representative representative
notter is recognized thank you mr
chairman i just have in my notes that mr
roberge
from the doe said that the bill doesn't
include specifics and the doe would have
to hire more people as consultants
and who knows how much that's going to
cost
thank you representative bernardi is
recognized
thank you mr chairman
i'm going to go back to the whole issue
of trying to quantify
environmental criteria as economic costs
i understand the other side of the aisle
believes this is a major economic issue
this side of the aisle does not
we are not in agreement with those
criteria
and you're asking a
public utilities commission then to come
up with an agreement when there is
disagreement within this country on how
to assess these costs if they are indeed
even costs
and this is inexpedient to legislate on
that basis alone
okay further discussion representative
oxenom
thank you mr chair
uh
i believe that representative
harrington's remarks missed the point
it's not about the day-to-day purchase
of fuels
what we're asking for here is that the
puc be in
enabled in its decision making to reckon
with the costs actual costs that have
occurred
when a rate setting
action is undertaken so that what the
utilities can come in
with a cost ask is this a just or
reasonable cost which the puc if it says
yes it's just unreasonable then goes
into the default service charge that's
that's the action here
it's not
airy fairy it's actual incurred costs
representative harrington
with all due respect i think people some
people in this committee don't
understand how rates are set this is
you're trying to go out and look and say
okay we're going to put a certain charge
on every megawatt that's produced from
natural gas a different charge on ones
that are produced from oil a different
one from coal
um maybe none on one from wind who knows
what you can come up with anything you
want and sign it but those are not in
the contracts the the supplier of the
power comes to the
the utility and says okay here's your
load demand here's our attempt at
meeting that load demand and they put a
proposal out and they may list 20 or 30
different contracts that they have they
may have contracts with someone who has
contracts with someone who generates
electricity and they might not even know
where the source of the electricity is
coming from but they have an obligation
to meet that contractual obligation by
supplying an electricity i know of no
contract that says so much percentage is
coming from solar or so much percentage
is coming from wind and if you don't
know that there's no way you can assign
a cost to it that's why we have the
renewable portfolio standing because we
give preferential treatment to renewable
energy by saying okay
if you every megawatt you produce you
get this piece of paper that says it's
uh you get one megawatt of worth of
wreck and now you can turn around and
the utilities must buy that they have no
choice so they go up and buy that and
that's how the renewables are rewarded
you can say we do the same thing with
generation on reggie where we penalize
the people that produce net and emit
natural gas and make them pay more for
it all those costs get built into the
rates but nobody on any given day can
come out and say what percentage is
going to be produced by what type of
generation it varies all over the place
you could have a
a similar fault at both seabrook and
millstone because they're very similar
nuclear plants the same generation
westinghouse for loop pressurized
reactors they could shut both plants
down and you'd lose 2400 megawatts
instantly the water the power is going
to come from someplace else but no one's
going to know where that is there's no
way you're telling so this this concept
that somehow we can put a price on
something when we don't even know where
it's coming from
is erroneous and again it's we already
cover that in the renewable portfolio
standard where we give preferential
treatment uh for renewables and we cover
it in reggie where we penalize uh
generators who produce uh carbon dioxide
representative oxidant thank you very
much i'm i i do believe that we are
speaking past each other representative
harrington
if if we go to the 378
sec 38
on the least cost integrated resource
plan
these plans by statute must include
forecast of future demand assessment of
demand side energy management programs
supply options including own capacity
market precursor
these are the kinds of issues we're
talking about not the issues that you
have been addressing
an assessment of distribution
transmission requirements an assessment
of plan integration and impact on state
compliance with the clean air act and
other environmental laws that may impact
utilities assets or customers so we have
in statute
a requirement for an assessment of
impact
of environmental laws that may impact a
utilities assets or customers
environmental laws are different
from the impact of climate change we
don't have that in law so we have no way
to put that into the consideration thank
you
representative oxendine we're straight
off the topic of the bill here you're
talking about other sections of law
and there's no amendment before us
so we're we're off topic we need to talk
about
the law that's before us or the bill
that's before us
and so i'd appreciate it if you could
confine your remarks to the legislation
that's before us
and i think i've already heard you say
that
as written it doesn't do
what you envision it to do and therefore
i would expect that you would vote to
support the motion of itl
am i right or not
go ahead well well close
as i said at the outset i think ols made
a mistake in putting this in 378 30 um
seven rather than in 37 or 38 where i
think it would have been better place so
i would recommend interim study so that
a better bill could be introduced ah
okay you didn't say that earlier but i
didn't get to my conclusion i was saving
that for the you know
okay
the big finish
the dramatic big fish that's what i see
okay any further discussion on this bill
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the roll on the motion of itl on house
bill 1250. i shall mr chair
representative thomas
yes professor harrington yes purpose of
notter yes representative mirner yes
representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
campbells yes representative pleasure
yes representative white yes
representative lewicki yes
representative massimilia no
representative kelly pitts
representative mann no
let me make representative oxendine
present first
representative oxenham
no
representative uh tallerski
representative mcgee
representative sykes no representative
creation
representative pimentel
representative partial
in the chair
yes
i have it as 12 to 10.
okay by a vote a surprising vote of 12
to 10
surprising only because i thought it
would be 21 to nothing because this bill
is totally
unimplementable as written
but anyway
by a surprising vote of 12 to 10 the itl
motion is adopted
and we will close the public hearing on
house bill 1250.
uh representative mcgee will
representative oxenoum be writing the
minority report yes okay
and i need that by
the end of day tomorrow
so if you could work on that tonight i'd
appreciate it
all right so now let's move on and i'll
open the executive session on house bill
dissolving the legislative oversight
committee to monitor the transformation
of delivery of electric services
and i recognize representative thomas
thank you mr chair uh before the
committee i have passed amendment
2022-0829-h
which i am introducing
and this amendment
addresses some of the
department of energy concerns they had
with the original bill and name changes
primarily and corrects a administrative
oversight
more importantly
uh if you turn to
if you turn it to a chapter five or
section five i should say of the
amendment
uh i've
changed the repeal
to repeal the committee but also the
duties that were that were overlooked
before to repeal the uh duties that go
along with that committee
i also in more importantly i've
preserved paragraph four f which was
inadvertently listed in the in the
original bill as a repeal i preserved it
so that we are ensured that the report
on the sbc gets not only done but
submitted to the department of education
as well
so the rest of the
yes there there there was there was a
one sentence in in the rsa that requires
the department of education to get a
copy of the citizens benefits charge
and by repealing
4f in my original bill it inadvertently
deleted that requirement for the
department of education to get that so i
i i uh
uh i corrected that
um what you see here are just other uh
corrections to change the name of the of
the commission and and the department
into what the department of energy wants
to see
so the crux of the bill eliminates the
oversight committee eliminates the
duties um related to the oversight
committee but
and make sure that any reports that were
originally
sent to the legislative oversight
committee in addition to other
committees that those reports still get
sent to the house science and tech
committee and also to the senate energy
committee as well
so
that's that's my discussion on the
all right uh two two things i would
entertain a motion to adopt this
amendment but only after each member of
this committee is provided with a copy
of the amendment yes clerk i had like
two copies
a copy was passed out to each member at
the beginning of the day
i don't have a copy
right here jeanine
here comes one where's jenny
we made 25 copies and then they're all
passed out
i actually gave it to you
are there any additional copies of the
amendment
i had put them right there
and they were pat and they were passed
around i even gave a stack to
representative mcgee to pass around her
what's that right there is that the
stack no those are my
body well here's next here's an extra
one
i made 25 copies
oh troy you can share mine you guys
didn't get one oh wait we've had copies
for me
kristen could you help us out here
please
no i know that upstairs did not i take
that all right let's be in order here
folks let's be in order kristin is going
to go get us some additional copies
i pass them out during caucus everyone
who does not have a copy please raise
your hand
okay we'll see how many we need
raise your hand if you need a copy of
this amendment one here that's mine
it looks like we need at least five
copies okay thank you
while kristen is obtaining additional
copies
i would entertain a motion to adopt the
amendment which is amendment number 2022
dash
representative thomas
uh i motioned to adopt the amendment
uh
089h
i second the motion to adopt the
amendment it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt the amendment
2022-0929-h
or
0829-h
is there
any discussion of the amendment
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman i'd just like a
little bit of education if uh
if someone would be able to inform me
what this legislative oversight
committee
does
right now and
why we should and should not have that
happen
continue i'll defer that question to
representative thomas who is the chair
of that committee uh thank you mr chair
as i explained during my public hearing
the original intent of this committee
was to
oversight of the divestiture
of the public utilities from the uh
generation
that purpose was uh obtained uh a few
years ago
and although there wasn't al although
there was a change made to the original
purpose of this committee
um
we real we haven't had any additional
meetings since then
and as i looked over various committees
that we may want to eliminate because
they've gone well past their smell test
i said we really don't need
to be
trying to put a square peg into a round
hole on a committee if we have a special
need for a commission
to
look at specific topics we can certainly
come forward with a bill at some future
date this particular bill i felt the
time was that we just get get rid of it
because
we really have no
no real need to be discussing
divestiture or any related items to that
right now
the commissions that have been adopted
in the past that do have value or things
such as the offshore wind commission
which has value i don't see value in
this commission to extend it as it is
and i don't want to keep
adding to or subtracting from it to make
something work when its life has been
extended has been extinguished so i
think it's better that we just delete
this
one here and next year if someone thinks
we need to have a commission to discuss
a specific area
by all means let's bring it forward and
we can discuss it
okay the question before us is on the
motion to adopt
amendment
0869 h
so let's
let's confine our discussion right now
to the amendment
once we adopt or reject the amendment
then we can have a discussion about the
original bill
so does anyone have a comment about the
amendment itself
representative callie pitts
uh
thank you
mr chair i'm a little bit confused
because when we were just doing a
discussion we went off just the
amendment
we went on to the background
and i don't know
who on this committee has sat
on the electric oversight committee i
have
for many years
and
i want to speak to that so when we adopt
the amendment that's the time to do that
that is correct all right thank you and
i apologize for allowing representative
pimentel's question i should have
i should not have accepted that question
because it wasn't about the amendment
and i apologize to the full committee
for that representative mcgee do you
have a question about the amendment i do
good thank you um the question is about
the testimony that um representative
thomas made already when i questioned
him on the department of energy
reference
and i
i don't know how that relates to this
amendment but i don't see anything in
here about the department of energy so
i'm just wondering which portion of this
amendment relates to that the
preservation of that that you said
would be here
you could just refer me to the line or
representative thomas yes
going to item
roman numeral 6
3 6
there was a reference made to the
department and the commission
and that was changed to environmental
services and the department of energy
oh okay you said education that's why no
i said i did say education but your your
direct question was for department of
energy so i was answering that one
if you want to if your question is
related to the department of energy
it it does not show in this amendment
because i did not
i did not repeal
for
subparagraph f
buried in four subparagraph f in another
line
it talk to department of education but
not in this amendment because it's not
being repealed so you eliminated the
repeal i eliminated the repeal which
preserves the department of energy line
and remember representative mcgee to ask
for permission to ask follow-up
questions as i was just going to say
follow-up okay follow-up
and the last thing i'll ask is um
on line 11
which is section 6
section
uh f under paragraph six um
it says that beginning in 2000
the department of environmental services
and the department of energy
um if we didn't have the department of
energy then is that
relevant should it say like and or or
should should it be said some other way
because it makes it sound as though
uh this has been ongoing since 2000 when
the department of energy wasn't in
effect in the last five or six years
well i i i would agree with your
confusion however i am responding to
requests from the department of energy
where they have told me that they are
trying to do a systematic review of all
rsas to more closely
relate to their new department
so that's that's the purpose of that
okay thank you
okay further discussion on the amendment
seeing none
representative callie pitts has a
question i just i'm going to question
that because that's retroactive
legislation and i didn't think we could
make retroactive
legislation
on anybody's request
that's a good point i think that this
issue could be addressed
in the senate
that's probably just a
fairly simple and quick
editorial change that needs to be made
representative flett
yes the suggestion to the senate is
remove the words beginning in 2000
correct
representative callie pitts i i guess
you know i probably had too much for
lunch but
uh
too much i didn't think we were supposed
to
refer to the body on the other side of
the wall and then ask them to do
something that we're not sure that they
can do
we should pass legislation that we think
is okay and if they mess with it or
change it that's up to them
but if we know that this is not correct
how can we do that
huh
i made a big
try to figure out what to do
all right i'm pretty sure representative
callie pitts to your question that
when the bill if this bill should pass
both bodies of the legislature when it
is enrolled
the ols enrollment committee will go
through it to make sure there are no
editorial errors
and i'd be i would be willing to bet
that they would see that beginning in
2000 as an editorial error and would
remove it
mr chairman
representative harrington thank you
this isn't highlighted so i'm assuming
that as the law exists right now it
already says beginning in 2000 the
so if that is correct if it's already
there we're not we're not changing that
part of the law we're changing
commission in the department to
department of environmental service in
the department of energy so we're just
leaving that part alone we're not doing
anything to it
that is correct that is correct
that
is not correct
representative kelly pitts
representative harrington i do believe
that
you were probably
on that second as old as i am
because in 2000 what we repealed was
there
but now we're saying beginning and that
wasn't there before
so
this legislation was effective
in 2000 that's when we had an oversight
committee
not
so that
doesn't hold and i would also point out
that ols
i assume
maybe i shouldn't approve this language
you couldn't follow up mr chairman
follow up just to try to clarify this
thing so i guess my question is what is
in the law right now does it say
beginning in 2000 the commission in the
department yeah okay so if that's
already in the law we're not changing it
with this amendment because that part of
the bill isn't highlighted we're only
changing commission and department to
department of environmental services and
department of energy
so i don't understand why there's a
problem it's just it's just staying the
way it is
mr chairman
uh representative occidum thank you
when you add in the new words you will
change the original meaning at the time
this was passed they were saying in the
future beginning in
and they talked about the existing
institutions now in 2022 we have
different institutions and because we're
adding in the name of the a new
institution it makes
no sense that beginning into it it this
it needs to be clarified and i love ols
they do a wonderful job but they didn't
do such a great job on the last bill we
just discussed and this whole issue of
going through and changing the do the
puc
to the department of energy has been
fraught
we've spent
almost a year i mean hb2 was fraught
with these issues we've had puc uh you
know the energy storage docket has been
held up because you know who's who's in
charge here and it's because they they
try to global replace everywhere you see
puc just stick in d.o.e
it doesn't work and it doesn't work in
this sentence
sure
okay uh representative thomas
yes mr chair if um
if if the committee wishes if if we
strike out the words beginning in 2000
comma
and begin the sentence with just the
department of environmental services
yada yada will that satisfy
this particular issue
representative uh oxenum
as an editorial change i i i think that
that i could support that but in the
larger issue if we ever get back to it i
want to know why we're dealing with all
these reports when but the point of this
bill
is to repeal an oversight committee okay
you answered the question let me see a
show of hands of everyone who would be
agreeable to the editorial change that
representative thomas just
indicated
okay everybody is agreeable to that so
i'm going to recess
the
executive session on house bill 1270
and i'm going to ask our committee
researcher kristin grant
to
come over here and talk to me about
taking this uh amendment to ols and
getting a new version
generated and we will come back to this
public to this exact exact session
when that
amendment becomes available
so could you
could you go to ols and ask them to
produce a new amendment that just simply
strikes
that phrase
and starts with the word the
with the term the
capital t
and otherwise
correct okay don't go anywhere anybody
because
even though i've recessed this pup this
executive session i'm going to start a
new one immediately
okay so 1270 is in recess until we get a
new version of the amendment
and now i'm going to open the exact
session on house bill 1285
relative to the
multi-use energy data
platform and i'm going to recognize
representative wiki for emotion thank
you mr chairman i move out to pass
representative wiki moves out to pass on
house bill 1285
representative white is recognized
thank you a second
it's been moved and seconded that we
pass
or judge
house bill 12 85 is to be ought to pass
and i open the floor for discussion on
that motion representative mcgee thank
you mr chairman just by way of
explanation folks because i had i had
mentioned to my folks earlier that we
the plan was to itl this bill so just to
clean up clear up any confusion
um originally we had agreed that the
language in this bill was
most easily dealt with by incorporating
it into another bill in front of this
committee tomorrow which is hb 1258
and the um amendment that came back
didn't include the language so it was
kind of a late-breaking thing and so um
just so that we can all be assured that
the language actually goes through we're
just going to pass it by itself
thank you any further discussion on this
legislation or this bill
well see none i guess we can call the
roll and i'll ask the clerk to do that
now thank you thank you mr chair uh out
to pass on hb 1285. representative
thomas
yes
representative harrington yes
representative notter
yes representative murder yes
representative platfords yes
representative berezini yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicky yes
representative massa milla yes
representative kelly pitts
representative mann yes alas
oxygen oxygen i'm in a second oxygen is
the second as soon as i make her present
let's see
there we go representative
are you still here yes oh you have to
vote representative
okay
representative telersky yes
representative mcgee yes representative
sykes yes representative
representative pimentel yes uh and the
chair
yes 22 to nothing
and i'd like to make a motion that we
put it on consent
by a vote of 22 to nothing house bill
is ought to pass and without objection
we'll go on to the
consent calendar
so thank you very much everyone
so i will now close the executive
session on house bill 1285
and we'll move on to the next bill which
is
i'll open the public the executive
session on house bill 1331
relative to power line maintenance and
construction
and i'll
recognize
representative flozier for a motion
thank you mr chair i moved to itl
house bill 1331
since new hampshire presently does not
license contract
oh i'm sorry
he's new
yes
i know
okay hang on a second folks
mr chair
yes representative pleasure i was
looking at
another bill i had
look at i made the wrong motion
would you withdraw your motion then
yes i would like to draw my itl motion
okay your itl motion is withdrawn
do you have another motion to make yes i
apologize for the first one mr chair
i thank you again
i moved to
ltp
a
house bill one three three one
okay representative um
it's been moved and seconded that we
pass
house bill 1331 with an amendment
and uh does anybody uh
have an amendment to offer chair
procedurally don't you come up with the
amendment first
typically you do yeah so where is the
amendment
the amendment was submitted at the time
of the bill
by representative baruti
and according to house rules
yeah the amendment number is
2022-01408
and according to house rules
when a bill is introduced and an
amendment is introduced simultaneously
the
amendment
can be adopted by the committee without
sponsorship
by a committee member
so
representative baruti is the sponsor of
2022-01408
okay so
could i have a motion from someone to
adopt
all right it looks like we're gonna have
to have to have copies made
a bit of a delay here
and uh
i'm going to try to get a discussion
going on the amendment
by reading to you
the difference between the original bill
and the amendment
so the original bill read as follows
any new hampshire utility customer that
requires a power line extension located
on private property
may hire a contractor who is licensed in
the state of new hampshire
and then the words
and is approved by the utility were
stricken
or struck
strzok is probably more correct
was the original bill
the amendment says
any new hampshire utility customer that
requires a power line extension located
on private property may hire a
contractor who is
and then these words were struck
licensed in the state of new hampshire
and is
and the following words were not struck
approved by the utility
so essentially the difference in the two
bills is
that a contractor
does not have to be licensed but he does
have to be approved by the utility
that's the difference between the
amended version and the introduced
version
so representative pled
mr chair this makes eminent sense
because
line crews are not licensed they're
trained by the utilities once they're
trained by the utilities they may become
independent contractors but they're
still trained by the utilities
recognized for their expertise
representative oxenom
yes as i recall from the public hearing
we took us a while to get there but we
finally realized there is no such thing
as this license that is being required
so what we're doing is removing a
requirement in the statute for something
that doesn't exist it's just
housekeeping
correct representative pementel
just a point of order
the motion was on the bill not on the
amendment
so we're going to have to correct i
asked for someone to make a motion on
the amendment and no one would
accommodate me because they didn't have
a copy of the amendment so right i
decided to initiate a conversation about
the amendment while we're waiting for
copies just to save time
so don't we don't we have to
remove the first motion first
no
okay
okay representative nader is recognized
i'll make the motion to um
pass the amendment when it gets here
okay representative notter has moved the
adoption of amendment 01408
is there a second second
representative thomas seconds the motion
now we can have some discussion on the
motion while we wait for copies of the
amendment representative callie pitts
i thought we could still have some
informal discussion but i'd like a
clarification
when we say licensed and we say
contractor and from my own mind
this would be a contractor to lay
the conduit
if that's what they're doing but not
attached to the poles
because
i i would believe that you need an
electrician to connect to
electricity
uh we even do that for solar panels we
require an electrician
to
connect the solar panels so
i'm confused on that and
a lot you need a licensed electrician
when you put in solar panels
uh so
what are we talking about are we talking
about connecting and attaching to a pole
i'm guessing that the original
legislation contained the words
licensed in the state of new hampshire
to cover
the fact that an electrician would be a
licensed electrician would be required
to
hook up the
the power to the pole
however
anybody who's approved by a utility to
do this work i would think
would have to be the utility wouldn't
approve that person unless they were
licensed it would seem to me
no license
so are we going to go around on this
again i i don't know i mean
may i follow up okay representative
kelly i'm just trying to get straight in
my mind
what these people are doing are they
actually connecting to the live
power lines and making an
interconnection
that's what it sounds like to me
and it sounds like to me
then that anybody
uh
could do this without being properly
trained
and i know approved by the utility but
how many people are out there working
and are not approved by the utility
representative sykes has a comment
uh yeah this is right thank you mr
chairman i actually have a tiny bit of
expertise about this having been as a
fire inspector for almost 30 years and
also the city's electrical inspector for
a short while
when we didn't have one um
electrical licenses count from the
meter in
they don't count from the drop
from the power utilities so there is no
license and there is not there is no
requirement for one
training is obviously required which
this amendment would uh would do
but anyways there's no there
to answer
the
there is no license there is no
requirement for a license the license
that you all refer to as the electrical
license applies to work with after the
meter
thank you for that clarification
representative lewicki
thank you mr chairman this would be a
further clarification where i live it is
typical for people to build a house at
the end of a quarter mile driveway
when they do that they will have a
transformer and a meter at the house and
a high voltage line will go from the
existing high voltage line using new
poles or whatever
to that transformer and that is i
believe what we're talking about is
bridging that gap between the
power lines that the power company puts
up and maintains and allowing a
connection to that which the power
company would actually make
okay representative plett yes
when i have the attention of the floor
um
mr sykes representative sykes was right
on the money
uh when you don't need electrician to
attach to a pole that's line work and
the utility will only hire line workers
that were trained by themselves or other
utilities
okay further discussion of this
amendment does everybody have a copy of
the amendment now
point of order
um is it possible to have in the motion
the actual amendment number two so that
there's no further confusion moving on
yes
representative notter would you withdraw
your previous motion and re thank you
state the motion
yes mr chairman i withdraw the previous
motion and the new motion is to pass
amendment number
2022-01408
and representative thomas
second
so it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt the amendment submitted originally
by representative baruti
to
clarify
just exactly what he was trying to do
with this bill
is everybody clear on it now does
everybody understand what we're doing
okay
it looks like there's no further
discussion on this amendment so i'd like
the clerk to call the role
on the motion to adopt amendment zero
one four h i shall do so mr chair
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representative notter yes
representative yes representative
platfors yes votes yes vote
representative berezni yes professor
bernardi yes represent campbells yes
represent yes representative white yes
representative lewicki yes
representative massa miller yes
representative callie pitts
represent a man yes
represent
who is present yes
i knew you were
i know
representative tallerski yes
representative mcgee yes previous sykes
yes representative creation
representative pementel
representative
uh the chair chairman
oh
representative partial
representative partial yes the reps and
the chairman yes
22-0
the amendment zero one four zero h is
adopted i'd now entertain a motion from
representative pleasure
thank you mr chair uh before i make that
motion can i make a clarification
i have in my hand
that amendment that had to be passed out
to anyone somehow i had that which
when representative brody spoke i even
have notes on him and it was closed at 3
55 pm on that date so i was confused on
now why everyone else doesn't have what
i had in my hand
so
just to
apologize for that
that was a confusion on my part
you have a motion to make
i'd like to make a motion to ought to
pass amended on
1331.
thank you representative pleasure moves
that we adopt the amended version of hb
1331 is there a second
all right
mr chairman i second that motion
okay it's been moved in seconded any
further discussion on this
amended bill
if not i'll ask the clerk to call the
roll
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended on 1331.
i shall do so mr chair
is there some confusion before i call
the roll
i had one other question i was trying to
ask representative lewicky anita
couldn't hear me if if something goes
wrong with this who's liable
if something goes wrong with this
extension the contractor is it the
contractor who is not licensed who
may not
be required to have insurance or is it
the utility
and
it's just a question and
it occurred to me because i i still see
somebody doing an extension
not maybe connecting to the home
but bringing it into the power bringing
it into from the main power line
who's responsible on this
uh just a question
it's an interesting question
representative lewicki mr chairman i
cannot speak with certainty but i would
expect that before the power company
would allow such a thing to be connected
they would do an inspection on their own
i agree
the contractor would be liable for any
issues
representative thomas
yeah thank you mr chair uh again uh
not speaking with any authority but
looking with
past example if a utility approves a
contractor to perform work and that
contractor
performs it badly and makes a mistake
i believe the liability would be both on
the contractor and the utility and one
example we can use on this is back a few
years ago when
forget the name of the gas company but
in lawrence massachusetts when they had
that tremendous tragedy
contractor was
very badly
trained i guess but the liability is
going back to the contractor and the and
the main gas company so
you are responsible if you hire a
contractor and you approve him to hire
and they make a mistake
i believe i believe you are liable as
well
so therefore they're going to make sure
that whoever they hire is properly
trained and meets their standards
any further discussion on this bill
seeing none i will now ask the clerk to
call the role on the motion of otpa on
hb 3 1331
thank you mr chair
uh representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative daughter yes
representative murder yes representative
pled votes yes representative berezni
yes professor bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes representative massa miller
yes represent cali pitts
representative mann yes as soon as i
make representative oxendine present
um representative oxendine yes
representative uh tallerski yes
representative mcgee yes representative
sykes
yes represent creatures represent
pimentel
representative partial yes and the chair
yes 22 to nothing
by a vote of 22 to nothing house bill
has been judged to be otpa without
objection it will go on the consent
calendar
seeing no objection
so ruled
and that closes the public hearing on
house bill 13 of the executive session
rather on house bill 1331.
all right
a quick time out here representative um
i mean uh kristen did ols give you any
estimate of when they might have this
okay
so we don't have an estimate all right
all right
all right well we'll move on next then
to
the next bill on our list which will be
the next to last bill
and so i will open the public hearing on
house bill 1459-fn
relative to recycling
solar panels and i will recognize
representative platt
i move to adopt
amendment number 2022-037-h
is there a second and i have copies in
front of me to pass out
representative not our seconds the
motion
and we will now pass out these copies so
that we can have a discussion about it
while it's being passed out what this
amendment does is to replace the bill up
other than the introductory class and
the only change in the replacement is to
substitute the word retailer for
manufacturer and that way we're chasing
local people not somebody in china or
elsewhere
and i want intended that when i had the
bill drafted but ols missed my email
and so we got a
i got it fixed
have some discussion with them
okay the discussion
is on
amendment
seven 2022-0378
on house bill 1459-fn
twenty-two
i screw up the account mr chair but i
did email it to every committee member
on thursday
last week
okay looks like we're going to be
retrieving additional copies of this
amendment
can you uh while we're waiting
representative plett can you point us to
the lines
of the amendment that are different from
the bill is introduced
line 28 the definition of retailer was a
manufacturer now it's retailer
it means a personal office affordability
module for retail sale in the state
through any means including but not
limited to remote offerings such as
sales outlets catalogs or internet sales
uh on 24 page two each retailer shall
prepare and submit a stewardship plan to
the department by
the later
letter of july 1st 2030 or within 30
days of reverse the first sale of a
photovoltaic module or in in or into the
state
uh line 27 describe how retailers will
finance the take back and recycling
system etc
on page 3 line 12 a retailer should
implement the
stewardship plan on line 13 a retailer
may periodically amended stewardship
plan
line thank you line 26 the retailer or
stewardship organization shall post this
report publicly accessible website line
28 beginning july 1 2028 no distributor
retailer installer may sell our offer
that i missed
line 36 retailer
34 retailer yes 34 35 36.
uh line one of page four retailer
a line two retailer
a line three retailer
uh line five retailer
line six retailers
it's everywhere yeah uh
10 retailer
11 retailers apostrophe s
uh line 15 retailer
line 21 retailers compliance
on line 23 including the retailer
925 department shall notify the retailer
and the retail shop
retailer shall provide stewardship plan
line 32 photovoltaic retailers
and that is it
all right huh
good job thank you high speed reading
well that retailing makes me want to go
shopping
so so the amendment is just
we can get to the substance in the
actual bill but this substitutes
retailer for manufacturer that's it
well any discussion prior to the
adoption of the amendment has to be
about the amendment itself
so
representative occidum you have a
comment about the amendment
i think i just got ruled out of order i
was hoping that we could discuss the
bills and the amendment doesn't offer
much grounds for
interest
okay does everybody have a copy of the
amendment at this point
no
oh
okay
all right why don't we take a bio break
and um
oh okay here we go
she would have been wondering if we'd
have done that
okay raise your hand if you need a copy
of the amendment please
everyone who needs a copy of the
amendment
oh really
there you go
all right does everybody now have a copy
of the amendment
okay discussion on the amendment
[Music]
as i read this it says that we're
amending the bill by replacing all with
the following
so
in fact
the the issue in
by passing this we we render moot
the bill i mean the discussion of
whether or not we should have this bill
is
appropriate to discuss now because this
amendment is replacing the entire text
with this text
technically that is correct so if you
would like to discuss the
amended bill
which would be this amendment then i
suppose that would be appropriate
representative plett i disagree but you
your chair rules of course but we're
just replacing manufacturing with the
retailer we still have to discuss the
bill as amended and you can have every
opportunity at that time
i suppose technically you are correct
let's let's let's amend the bill and
we'll discuss that
let's amend the bill and then discuss
the amended bill so
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
roll on the
motion to amend
h.b 14 59 fn
with 2022-037-h
mr clerk
thank you mr chairman
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter
yes representative murder yes
representative platt votes yes
representative berezner yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils
yes represent yes representative white
yes representative wiki yes
representative massa miller yes
representative callie pitts
represent man yes
representative oxenoum
yes
you are president but
every one of these i have to change
representative tallersky yes
representative mcgee yes representative
sykes yes represent creation
representative pimentel
representative partial
okay just drove me up
yes
i haven't asked yet but representative
votes yes
21 to 1. okay by a vote of twenty one to
one
amendment zero three three seven h is
adopted
i now recognize representative plett for
a motion
just one second sir wally
record the vote
uh yes i move ought to pass as amended
uh for house bill
1459 fn and i'd like to speak to my
motion oh i second the motion first it's
been moved and seconded that we adopt
the amended version of house bill 1459
fn and representative platt is
recognized
small electronics already have a program
through and municipalities
for recycling
most larger facilities go to a site
evaluation committee and they have they
have imposed a recycling end of end of
end of
term recycling
solar panels don't necessarily go
through a site evaluation committee
because they may be on homeowners roofs
and they may be smaller
and so that's the purpose of this any
facility within new hampshire of any
size should have a end of life plan
and
this these
solar panels
a lot of it's glass no big deal
uh but
but a lot of it is uh heavy metals and
there's all sorts of stuff in there
selenium lanthanum cerium presodium
neodymium i'm not going to promote some
of the others but they they have to be
carefully sorted out and recycled it's
somewhat of an elaborate process
recognize that cost up front and the
only opposition when this occurred was
from one solar representative who
essentially said let's kick the can down
the road we don't need to do it now but
we do need to do it now thank you
further discussion on the motion to
adopt
house bill 1459 as amended
representative
harrington
thank you mr chair this is more of a in
the form of a question
um
looking at this bill it sounds as if
what we've done is it's up to the people
selling the solar panels to have a
program set up for recycling at end of
life
but you know in today's world i go on
the internet i find a solar panel i want
to buy from mexico
and the they ship it put it in a ups
truck and it shows up in my house a
couple of days later how is the
department of energy from new hampshire
going to enforce any mandates on a
country
company in mexico
that's for the department of energy to
work out but if there's a solar panel
retailer
operating in mexico selling into this
state they can't sell without getting
the department of energy approval with
the recycling plan period
i understand that but how is the
department of energy going to know about
fred's uh
uh gas station and solar panels down in
some place in mexico i look them up on
the internet they ship when i send them
the money
i don't i just i'm trying to figure out
how this is enforceable a lot of the
things we have now are like you have to
recycle like a battery because if you
want to buy a new battery you have to
turn in the old one or they're going to
charge you for it
or other things like that i'm just
trying to figure out how the department
of energy is even going to know that i'm
buying solar panels from somebody in
mexico and putting them up on my
backyard i mean there's no requirement
for me to report to them on it and
presumably the company could
just sell me the panels i put them up
and no one knows the difference okay mr
ch
in response mr chair may i
follow up go ahead page three
lines twenty eight through thirty one
part no distributor retailer installer
may sell our offer for sale or photo
module into the state unless the
retailer
of of the module has submitted to the
department of stewardship plan now that
doesn't get to the enforcement the 31 on
gets the enforcement department shall
send a written warning to a retailer is
not participating in a plan the written
warning shall inform the retailer that
shall be submitted plan or participate
in playing within 30 days of the notice
the department may assess a penalty up
to ten thousand dollars upon a retailer
for each sale
and if that doesn't work i guess it's a
lawsuit
follow up
follow up yeah see that that's my point
again we've got someone from the
department of energy are they going to
be monitoring all internet sites for
looking for people that may be selling
solar panels for any place across the
world how would they even know that
somebody in new hampshire had bought a
solar panel and who they bought it from
because there's no upfront there's no
national registration or whatever that
i'm aware of so this this law is out
there but the guy in mexico doesn't even
know it exists
and if someone goes on the internet the
average homeowner is not going to know
it exists
so they just order their their solar
panels and they show up and they install
them and i just i don't see how this is
enforceable and i don't see where the
department of energy is going to be able
to impose fines on
companies in other countries
respond again sure
yes go ahead
page 2 149 m63
9910 the department shall develop
guidance for module stewardship program
take back program etc
uh and it lays out there
but my point
with due respect representative herring
you say do do nothing
let it happen
have these things uh proliferate
if i can respond to that mr chairman yes
go ahead what i'm saying is that you've
identified a real problem i agree but
i'm not sure this is a real solution
because it's just a paper tiger there's
no enforcement mechanism and i don't see
how the department of energy is going to
be able to patrol the world for solar
panels coming into new hampshire where
literally that's the market you can buy
them from now and if i buy solar panels
from uh bulgaria or some place and they
show up uh i don't have to notify the
department of energy of that there's no
requirement for me to do anything the
best i can see other than to install
them and so they're going to be there
and then
20 years from now i've got old solar
panels i've got to get rid of some place
i'm not sure that this i just don't see
how this is going to solve there's a
real problem i agree but i don't see
this as a real solution
representative thomas
thank you miss chair i looked at my
notes and during the public hearing i
unless i'm incorrect i i didn't see any
testimony from the department of energy
on this bill
but uh perhaps since they're here now
would this be a valid
question ask them
what they think of this
i doubt they would respond but we could
ask i suppose
mr roberge do you
have any interest in responding to
general questions about this legislation
even though the department did not
testify
at its public
hearing
thank you mr chairman i think my answer
is going to be brief page one line nine
department means the department of
environmental services so
we're out
good answer good answer good answer
thank you
mr chair i was about to point that out
okay thank you
uh representative lewicki has a question
or a comment thank you mr chairman and
thank you representative um one question
i have is that
the world of retail is quite uh
fluid
and what
would happen if for instance as happened
i think elon musk bought the biggest
solar retailer in the country and then
essentially collapsed it
what happens is the retail landscape
changes and retailers that might be in
existence one day or one year
cease to exist
representative platt
my response is i would expect the
department of environmental services to
have some payment plan
so that even if they collapse there's
money there to recycle them uh as as
nuclear has
has a a payment plan so that by the time
a nuclear plant
shuts it down there's plenty of money to
to close the plant down and i tell you i
did run this by the department of
environmental services they took no
position on the bill but i heard from
the staffer that it was very well
written
representative
mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um i was just looking through the
testimony that we received on the bill
and while i um i see you know points
being made by everybody along the way uh
decommissioning a nuclear power plant is
a really different thing than somebody
who's an individual that owns you know a
solar array um
and the larger uh installations already
have decommissioning plans they're
required to
and we also had testimony that there
really haven't we don't have any issue
with
solar panels
ending up in landfills so i'm wondering
whether the bill is uh you know a
solution in search of a problem i
understand that there can be a problem
with people
disposing of solar panels in a way
that's not responsible
but when i look at this bill i think
it's it's heavy-handed and i think it's
also
targeting really just one industry we
don't require this for any other
uh any other industries of these type
oil furnaces gas furnaces heat pumps we
don't have decommissioning plans for
individual power generation in general
and
and i think it kind of sends the wrong
message as well because
it adds an additional cost and an
additional complexity to people
participating in the market here in new
hampshire which i think is the opposite
effect that we're trying to have which
is to have competition and allow the
markets to help us decide
um i think the bill is premature in that
it's trying to solve for something that
is really not an issue in new hampshire
and i would understand the argument
saying well we don't want it to become
an issue but i would also submit to you
that
people who tend to
invest in solar either on their roofs or
as solar arrays to help augment their
electric costs are generally people who
are already very conscientious of the
environment
and so the idea of them
tossing something off into a landfill is
probably inconsistent as well
further discussion
representative oxenom
thank you mr chairman
we we have another bill which is
currently in a different committee hb
hb111
or 1111
which is to establish a commission to
look at extended producer responsibility
and i think i think we have a solution
in in the making here which would render
um the necessity for for this
moot
with extended producer responsibility
by keeping the
emphasis on the producer and not the
retailer it encourages a redesign
such that when you're producing the
product you're looking at the best way
to recycle all of the elements
and and that is really the way that
we're going to reduce our our waste
stream which is in danger of
overwhelming many municipalities and
costing
many of our
towns
putting a real stress on their budgets
so i i would suggest that we
not support this bill
but that we look to
hb 1111 and that commission to supply us
with a broad
a broad
sec broad spectrum solution to a major
problem that we are facing we we
certainly on on this side of the aisle
support your effort to to look at
recycling to look at the reclamation of
materials but i i don't think this
particular bill is the best way to do it
thank you representative mann is
recognized
yes i'm i'm just curious what the what
is the problem are the is there a
toxicity to the
spent solar panels
yes very much so yes
and we don't want municipal
uh
waste disposal
sites to end up having to deal with that
toxicity well because small towns just
simply can't afford it right but i'm
just trying to figure out the toxicity
issue what what is it about the panels
that makes them difficult to reach just
simply leave on the ground
a representative plet can answer your
question line 25 page
one
lanthanum cerium prosodium neodymium
promethium samarium europium gadolinium
terbium dispersed dysprososium or
whatever homium erbium thulium
interberbia
luditium ethereum or scandium are they
toxic
yes is any of them toxic yes
and representative thomas is recognized
thank you miss chair uh
going back to a previous
representative's comments
as a lot of we have a lot of experience
of
not knowing which bills are going to
pass and not pass in the house and
certainly not which ones may make it
through the senate so
i recommend that we pass this bill and
if
hb111 passes as well these types of
bills can be worked out either in the
senate or committee of conference
or or
wherever or the time of the house votes
we can decide which one at the time but
without
we can we cannot rely on one bill that
might pass in some other committee so i
recommend that we pass this bill
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman uh an issue that's
going to
uh be a problem in 20 years i think we
could wait a year
to pat to try and pass a different bill
uh number one
number two um
uh here here on
hp 11 11.
uh
the
when i
have my refrigerator that i need to
bring
to the
uh
the local
recycling center
i have to pay a fee so that they can
remove the
um
the the the freon or whatever
whatever the refrigerant is in it
and uh so there is
a fee that i pay at the end of the life
of that appliance
um
i anticipate the same thing will happen
with our solar panels
um i would think that anyone who is
putting solar panels on their roof know
that at some point they're going to have
to be replaced
and they
i would think they would know there's
going to be a cost to that
the the
right now in europe
they are
they have
large
recycling operations
one of them that is in service right now
can
take care of 50 of all the solar panels
in
the european union
and recycle 95
plus percent of the
heavy metals in those
solar panels
that's
a plant for the entire
eu
i can't imagine that we would be able to
have the economy of scale here in new
hampshire
to
do that kind of recycling
so
this really is going to be
a national issue not a local issue
as far as how this gets done so i think
that we're this is probably premature
but i do commend you on your
wish to make sure that these heavy
metals don't get into the waste stream
representative callie pitts
i think that
we need to look at or i'm going to look
at what my goal is right now
and i think one of our goals or my goal
would be to encourage people to
go to solar
not discourage and i think at this point
in time
and timing is everything this bill
would discourage because the costs of
all this if they're born by the reit
retailer i'm going to be cos passed on
to the customer and the customer at
right now
in this environment
can't
bear another quarter
we also know that we have problems with
recycling
with recycling your computer with
recycling everything because those
things used to be taken care of and the
way they were taken care of stopped for
a while so that
i don't know what happens to it when i
bring it to i call it the dump the
transfer station i don't know what they
do with it i give them money and and
there it goes but i don't know
if there is anybody pulling the lithium
out pulling i don't know that
and with proliferation of all not just
solar panels
houses don't have have two three
computers two three televisions
everything we use is toxic
including the plastic the bottle i have
right here
what
we have to figure out first what we're
going to do with it and then we have to
discard we have to encourage
more use to save on the other end
and i don't think we've gotten there yet
and i think this bill
needs more discussion
and
we need to put our collective heads
together and come out with a plan
i think that's vitally important we
talked about uh
nuclear waste we don't know what to do
with that yet either they haven't
figured out what to do with me yet
either so i think that
i mean we've had all kinds of hair but
you laugh but we've had all that kind of
hair chemically do this do that
nobody knows so we have to uh
we have to appreciate the work
we have to appreciate the idea but the
timing is wrong
representative wiki
thank you mr chairman
i
it may be that a different approach
would work better i'm responsible for a
very old house down in another state and
i got a thing in the electric bill that
said we'll pay you 75
for a refrigerator i had a
70 year old refrigerator literally that
i had to get rid of and i got 75 dollars
for it and
given that
these solar panels are to a great extent
going to be connected to the grid the
electric companies should know who has
them if they cease producing electricity
or if something changes they should know
and it may be that that would be a
better conduit for the recycling
okay representative partial
thank you chair vows um
i think that i applaud the idea of
making our producers of these products
more responsible
i'm afraid that it was put
undue burden upon my local solar
retailer and calls me to maybe seek
another solution
elsewhere which does not benefit my
local community
that's part of my concern and the others
by signaling out the solar industry
um i mean we have
we have tires that are jamming my
landfill not solar panels we have
plastic bottles that are jamming my
landfill and these are being produced
uh with no regard of how
they're going to be disposed of i think
a more comprehensive solution might i
would applaud that and i would hope that
we could maybe seek that together
a solution that addresses not just solar
panels but everything that we produce
right now
and try to find the wisest and least
burdensome way for our municipalities to
dispose of them
and uh
and thank you
thank you
um we are are expecting an amendment
from ols for house bill 1270.
um
kristen do you have any news about that
oh it's already here oh wonderful okay
so
here's what i'd like to do i'd like to
take a a recess in this public hearing
and i would like to ask everyone except
the majority party to clear the room so
that the majority party can have a quick
caucus
and i would like to have everyone return
to the room
at 2 30
for the resumption of this
executive session and then after we
finish that we will resume the executive
session on 1270.
so we're officially in recess on 14 59
until 2 30.
our activity for
today
now we recessed
back around 210 or so we recessed
the public hearing on house bill 1459 fn
executive session sorry
so i am here to announce that we will
resume the executive session on house
bill 1459
on tuesday
march 9th
at 10 a.m
in the interim
there will be some additional work done
on the bill to clarify some of the
questions that were asked
during the course of our discussion over
the executive set during the executive
session earlier
so we will resume that
executive session on tuesday march 9th
at
10 am
march 8th i i think i met
yeah wednesday march wednesday march 9th
recycling of solar panels
next wednesday
well actually maybe we should do it
march 7th because
we have a
we have a conflict well let me tell you
let me let me suggest this
i have to consult with
the other committee that occupies this
room on the days when we don't to find
out if march 9th is available if it is
we'll do it march 9th if it's not
we'll do it on march 7th
okay so
reserve both march 7th and march 9th at
10 a.m
for the resumption of the public of the
executive session on 1459.
this is 306 308. yes
they are okay so it looks like we'll
probably have to have it on the seventh
then
because we have a bunch of issues to
resolve
so
we have to consult with des and
get some questions answered so
all right we'll schedule it for march
7th then
10 a.m
and i'll make sure that gets into the
calendar for uh this upcoming week
so
with that
we can now resume
the public hearing on house bill
execs
exec session on house bill
and all of you should have received by
now
an amendment
that
on page two
beginning with line 11
strikes the words beginning in 2000 the
commission and the department
and starts the sentence with the word
the
the department of environmental services
and the department of energy sal submit
blah blah blah
now this is amendment number
080h
and i would entertain a motion to adopt
this amendment representative thomas
thank you mr chair um i move to adopt
2022-0880h
representative notter is recognized i
second the motion
it's moved and seconded that we adopt
amendment
zero eight eight zero h
is there any discussion
further discussion i should say
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the roll on the adoption of amendment
zero eight eight zero h to
house bill 1270.
the the delay is for me to change the
amendment number just a second
zero
okay uh
commencing the roll call representative
thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative knighter yes
representative yes representative platt
votes yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils yes
representative pelosi yes representative
white yes representative wiki yes
president of massimilia yes
representative kelly pitts
representative mann aye
yes
got it
a representative of oxygen
present yes
i already took care of the president
okay um where am i representative
tellerski yes
representative mcgee yes representative
sykes
yes represent creation
representative pimentel yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes 22-0
okay the amendment is adopted
so now i'd entertain a motion to
opt to pass with amendment house bill
1270 representative thomas
thank you mr chair i uh
moved to uh to um
i moved to otpa uh 1270. representative
knotter
it's moved and seconded that we adopt
house bill 1270 with amendment zero
eight eight eight zero h
is there any further discussion
representative callie pitts
i'll be brief because i want to go home
just like everybody else
i
i probably am the one of the only ones
on this committee who served on the
electric oversight committee and when it
was
the uh
redistrict
my mind is brilliant restructuring
restructuring committee and i've been on
it ever since
and in the last two years and i was not
appointed again
one of the things that the committee
does that's very important i believe
is when these reports come out
we request the people you make a report
you make a report you make a report
the committee
hears those reports
here's the presentations
discusses those presentations and go
over them
if you look at one of the charges it's
to of the committee would be to look at
the changing climate or the changing
atmosphere what electricity is going to
be
and i think that's very important and to
guide us along the way
covid
dropped in on us unfortunately
and we really haven't had a chance for
these committees to do what they have to
and then report back to us which is what
the committee does
most times when these reports come out
i'm not going to say they get circular
filed but pretty close
they go to the committee they don't go
to everybody in the committee they're
posted online and
usually you don't get them the committee
has a chance these these smaller
committees have a chance to
go into depth and to probe the
information
we usually don't have that kind of time
or we haven't had it in the past couple
of years
and i understand covet intervened but we
won't do it
so i think that getting rid of these
committees
is very
very important
we're having a major overhaul in our
electricity delivery delivery system
just like we did with restructuring
things are changing
and you don't need
superficial or rushed discussion
you need in-depth probing
and planning
and a commission can do that and make
the proper recommendations
to this committee we're not all
experts i'm not an expert i i don't know
there's several on this committee that
are experts
but i need somebody to explain it and
explain it in depth
what is
this says this but what does it really
mean
and i think that to take this committee
away at this juncture we're on the brink
of changing our form of energy
i think it's a mistake because i don't
think this committee can handle it i
don't think des by themselves can handle
it
there was a time when des was forbidden
to talk about certain subjects
you can't tell a committee you can't
talk about this committee can talk about
whatever they really want to what's in
their
what's in their purview and anything
else that's pertinent
so i think that we
really are doing a disservice we may
have a lot of committees that
are not important or don't meet i won't
say they're not important every
committee is important but i think that
this is a committee that can really do
the in-depth service
when it gets up and running again
and
i just think that we need to have that
that's all and i'm probably again one of
the only ones that served on those
committees and served when they were
really important and they are going to
become important again if restructuring
was important
and restructuring was a major job
what is this new energy that we're going
to
envision and happen in the future and
how are we going to guide that
for the state of new hampshire
that's really
really important
thank you
thank you representative kelly pitts is
one of the other people serving
currently serving on this committee who
has also served on the oversight
committee
i remember on
one or two maybe more
occasions that we
got a presentation from someone or some
organization about a topic of interest
to
committee members about
the energy sector
and i can remember thinking at the time
well these presentations are are quite
informative
and i wondered to myself why are we
limiting these presentations to just
this oversight committee
the entire ste ought to be
hearing these
presentations
and i believe that's true
and one of my goals
for the rest of this year is to set up
several such presentations
for this committee so that every single
member of this committee can elevate his
knowledge his or her knowledge base
so that we can understand the issues we
face more thoroughly
and i concur with representative thomas
that the oversight committee has
outlived its usefulness
but that doesn't mean that we have to
ignore the good sources of information
that are out there that we can all take
advantage of and we can set up these
presentations to the full committee
and people can attend
at their own choice whether they if they
want to attend they can if they don't
they don't have to
so
i'm
that's by way of telling you that i'm in
support of the itl
or the uh the uh obelisk abolition of
the committee but i'm not
uh in favor of denying this committee
the opportunity to learn more about what
we do
fun go ahead the oversight committees
were never
ever
limited to the oversight committee
anyone could attend those meetings they
have to be posted just like everything
else
and anybody could attend so they were
not limited
but they could be
long
representative pimentel you had a
comment
thank you mr chairman when when the bill
originally came up and we found out that
uh
some of the things that were supposed to
happen with the committee we were
supposed to get a report
which i was unaware we got and
and found out that it was actually sent
to you and you said
that you had sent it to all of us
and i went back and checked my email and
there it was um
it was a report that
i did read at the time but i didn't know
what it was and why i was getting it
and
and i guess that was that's a problem
with
uh
the whole thing right now is that i
feel like
it should have gotten to some place and
somehow been reviewed as the as a group
and
you know
not just
read
singularly and try to digest what i
could from it but to actually have a
conversation about it and that didn't
happen
and
whether this committee is dissolved or
not i mean the the issue is that that
should have been discussed
that's my comment
that's a good point and
i think going forward maybe we should
schedule some committee sessions some
committee work sessions to discuss these
reports that we get
and sit down and talk about them
together go through them and and see if
we can understand them and find out what
their implications are
representative plett
yes uh afterwards
a change in focus a year or so ago it's
now the
legislative oversight committee to
monitor the transformation of delivery
of electric services
and frankly that's pretty stable the
delivery is the delivery and so i don't
see any need for this committee to exist
anymore however if it however
if somebody sees a need for to look at
the different energy sources in the
future and how that might change you can
always create a committee to do that or
commission
thank you representative masimilio
so am i correct
in saying that
the committee's
responsibility would be taking over by
des and the department of energy or no
you say that again who's taking what
from des
if the committee is dissolved
would des and then the department of
energy be responsible for what the
committee was responsible for or no
no the the des and and department of
energy are responsible for generating
reports and we are the recipients of
those reports
but they have no responsibility about
what we do with those reports
and so the oversight committee
as i recall when i served on it didn't
really spend much time looking at those
reports itself
the chairman of the committee frequently
brought in people to make presentations
to the committee and they were open
meetings as representative callie pitts
pointed out they weren't restricted just
to the members of the committee anybody
could attend
yes go ahead follow up so what was the
responsibility of the committee
representative callie pitts can help me
answer that question my recollection of
the responsibility of the committee was
simply to
provide oversight originally when it was
the way it was established to provide
oversight of the restructuring process
which turned out to be a 20-year process
but it finally was finished
about two years ago
and that's one of the reasons why
this bill exists
since the committee's original purpose
has been
delivered on
completed
there seems to be no more need for this
committee to exist
did i have that right representative
callie pitts the initial responsibility
was to oversee you correct
restructuring and and the impact on the
state in new hampshire
and to see that everything went smoothly
and that was i believe that was
accomplished fairly well
if restructuring is over my answer to
that is it is not
we are in the process of restructuring
the way our energy is delivered
and how and and how we get it
and that's not going to be 20 years when
you say the stability of the uh of the
energy delivery system
will everybody's panic and shaken a
little bit about what happens when the
grid goes out
what happens with a cyber attack what
and and are our responsibility as an
elected
committee would be to say
how are you prepared what are you doing
for these things and to probe those
things in debt
as i brought out here when we had they
had testified and had the storm
we were told well you know there was
this there was that there was the other
thing the thing was they didn't have the
equipment to get it back they didn't
keep enough storage
and the committee took care of that and
said you will
and you will report to us about where
you stand and how much you can withstand
uh and it wasn't drivers or anything it
was just basic equipment
now to me more than ever it is critical
to stay on top of those issues
and we hear that all our agencies
department of energy in particular oh
we've got to hire another person oh
we're
outstretched somebody's got to do it and
it's it's work that is important
it's not important now maybe
but when something happens
if we're prepared it's very important
that's not only emergency preparedness
this is checking with the utilities how
are you keeping your stock what are you
doing
uh i think
again
committee or no committee
which i'm sure this is going to fail
this bill is going to pass
that somebody and this then this
committee as a whole
has to take on that role and be sure
that our delivery systems are where they
should be in this state
that
our energy transition is what it should
be because we are in restructuring make
no mistake about it
and that that goes
smoothly we need to keep on top of it
not that we can do it
but we need to keep on top of it and
make sure we know how things are going
and a committee
has the authority to ask for that
information so does this committee
but does this committee by itself have
the time the other advantage of a
committee like that is it has members of
the senate on it
who sometimes show up and who sometimes
don't
but at least that allows us to work
together
so those are the important things
and that's all
that's enough
i would point out that
restructuring had a very precise
definition to it
when the oversight committee was
created to oversee restructuring
restructuring
as defined at the time
didn't mean
well where are we going in the future it
meant
how are you going to accomplish the
divestiture divestiture of generation
devices to become
simply delivery
vehicles for electricity that was the
definition of restructuring
and we've accomplished that that has
happened
that divestiture has been completed you
were using the word a few minutes ago
restructuring in the sense of where are
we going in the future and while that's
an important topic
i would argue that the creation of the
department of energy by hp2 last summer
has given us a vehicle
for
watching the development of energy in
the future and plotting where that
future may go the department of energy
has a policy role to play
in developing
what will happen in our energy future
and
i don't think that we need this
oversight committee
when we have the department of energy
which hasn't even had a really an
opportunity yet to show
how it can
guide our energy future i think we need
to let it
show us what it can do
and we don't really need
a separate committee
of this committee a subcommittee of this
committee to do that
even if it does include some members of
the senate because
let's face it when the radio when this
committee was redefined two years ago
its purpose was defined in such a way
that was so vague
that as representative thomas has
pointed out the committee hasn't even
met for a couple years now covet had
something to do with that i agree but
the the
the definition of the committee's
purpose was very vague in that previous
legislation and it hasn't served the
committee well
i
respond because there was two things
when restructuring happened the first
thing we had to do was find out if we
were going to restructure
and how that would affect us the second
thing that that i take a little bit of
umbrage was was that the des makes
policy they do not the legislature makes
policy and if they if if they are making
policy they shouldn't be they should be
following policy the legislature is the
leader
they inform us they tell us what they
need
and then we ultimately decide is this
what you want so those are two things i
would point that but
i'm not going to belabor it anymore
whatever happens this committee and this
legislature is responsible
but what
regulatory
agencies do is they
oversee
policy and they implement policy so
the
the doe has a role to play as an
overseer to make sure that policies that
have been implemented and procedures
that have put in place rules that have
been been put in place
are followed
and
i think that's part of what the
oversight committee used to do but it
doesn't need to do that anymore
representative mcgee did you have a
comment
um
yes i did
um i think you know we're we're probably
predisposed in different ways to look at
the value of having
an oversight committee made up of folks
who are in the legislature versus inside
an agency
you know under the executive branch and
how policy gets determined
it could be the whims of the political
nature versus
um you know elected folks who are who
are working uh giving their time trying
to come up with the best solutions for
the state and i'm not saying that the
folks in our agencies don't have the
best interests of the state in mind i'm
sure they do
but i guess
we're seeing a number of bills that are
taking aim at
at
oversight stakeholder processes
and things that were put in place to try
and help us have
separate entities that would then advise
us
and bring information to us because we
don't really have the time in this
committee
to do
we don't do discussions around oversight
and what we're trying to accomplish in
the year we just all bring in our
different bill ideas and we fight for
them and then we vote on them
and so it i think that this
committee from my understanding the
legislative oversight committee played a
different role
which
uh although your explanation recently uh
mr chair was that
it might be appropriate under policy for
that to go into the doe and we'll see
whether or not they fill that role
i don't think it i have heard it
described as one of their roles and so
that that's
my concern is that we will be
eliminating something that is of value
to us and to the state
because we didn't understand what value
it could play and we are at least still
in a transition we may not be in the
transition that started the committee
but um but in terms of questions that
need answers around how we go forward
we are still in that place
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman
this legislative oversight committee
um
right right now it is uh
what they've been uh
tasked the tasks they were
to fulfill
may
or may not be complete i'm not really
sure
but
the need for a legislative oversight
committee
is
i think
extremely important and to actually
um
basically
kill this committee
and
and not have a replacement it seems to
me that
if we want to do something
that makes a lot more sense maybe
give the legislative oversight committee
a different um
uh a different
goal
than
the goal that this committee was given
but not to actually
um
absolve the
uh dissolve the committee completely
we really need an oversight committee
so it should just be
[Music]
given another purpose
not
dissolved
further comment
or discussion
all right seeing none i guess i'll call
on the clerk to uh call the roll on the
motion of ought to pass
on house bill
70. ought to pass as amended on house
bill 1270 mr clerk
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative yes
representative yes representative plett
says yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes representative massa miller
yes
representative kelly pitts
representative mann
yes
yes representative oxendine
no
uh representative tallerski no
representative mcgee no
representative sykes
no it's not working no
there's maybe too many mics on if it's
not working when you get a green some
too many other bikes are on
representation no
representative pimentel
representative partial yes
and the chair
yes
fourteen through mississippi
fifteen
sixteen
i counted sixteen
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen through
the wiki
fourteen fifteen
sixteen
and uh the no's
are one two three
four five six seven
yeah
miss mark somebody
huh
okay
then i have somebody marked down i
shouldn't i have those as yes thomas
says yes harrington is yes nodder is yes
murderer is yes plent is yes but he is
yes bernardi is yes campbell's is yes
claudia is yes white is yes luiki yes
massimilia yes
uh man yes
and partial yes
16.
one two three four five six 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 through the wiki
14.50 five six seven eight
sixteen that's too many
i everyone's staying fifteen but i'm
counting sixteen
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
all right
it's confusing when you both scroll
along and they
blur together okay all right i can't
even get committee will be in order
please
let's hold the chatter down so the kirk
clerk can count i can't even get to that
screen to change it
something the key must be stuck
yes 15 to 7. okay by a vote of 15 to 7
house bill 1270
is adopted as amended
will there be representative mcgee will
there be a minority report
representative callie pitts
no minority report okay
all right
well thank you everyone i'm going to
close the exact session then on house
bill 1270
and i'm going to thank you all for a
great day's work
but before i let you go
we're going to do this again tomorrow
starting at 10 o'clock and
i would like you all to anticipate
whether or not you think there'll be a
minority report
for
any of the bills and please have someone
assigned to write it and potentially
even write it tonight
you do
okay great that would be wonderful and
i'll remind all the report writers for
majority reports or committee reports
that you have to have your reports into
me by
the end of our session tomorrow
so by five o'clock tomorrow afternoon i
have to have all those reports
so that i can get them to the clerk to
the
committee admin by wednesday morning
so does anybody else have anything they
would like to bring before the committee
before we close for the day
okay seeing nothing i'll see you all
tomorrow morning and thanks for your
hard work
you